So, da bin ich wieder.
Excellent.
Ach ja.
Ich sehe gerade, ich bin noch sogar relativ früh.
Normalerweise bin ich ja erst nach 10 und 08, 07, 09 Monat.
Huge Subscriptions, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Äh, geht.
So, also, was gucken wir uns denn heute an?
Ist irgendwas passiert, die letzten Tage über, wo ich noch meinen Senf zugeben muss,
bevor wir anfangen, Videos anzuschauen?
Ich weiß gar nicht, war, war noch irgendwas, ähm, lass mal überlegen.
Ja, dass die ganzen China-Miner ihre Grafikkarten verkaufen, das habt ihr wahrscheinlich mitbekommen, ne?
Die Chinesen, also die, die chinesischen China-Chinesen haben ja, ähm, Crypto-Mining verboten.
Und jetzt verkaufen alle Chinesen ihre Grafikkarten.
Aber es wird uns nichts bringen, weil die verkaufen das alle auf so einem chinesischen Ebay,
wo du die Sachen selbst abholen musst und sowas.
Oder in China wohnen und das ist halt für uns recht uninteressant.
Ach ja, und was ich auch witzig fand, ist diese, diese News hier.
Warte mal, die muss ich euch grad mal zeigen.
Das hat auch letztens einer im Stream, letzt, letztens einer im Stream schon, schon gepostet.
Aber jetzt kam das bei Heise auch.
Ups, warum, warum geht das jetzt nicht? Warte mal.
Ja.
Hat wieder irgendeiner E-Mail-Anhänge geöffnet bei einer Stadtver, irgendeiner Stadtverwaltung.
Also ich könnte wetten, es hat wieder irgendeiner E-Mail-Anhänge geöffnet.
Ich frag mich immer.
Vor allem diese Bilder dabei, WTF, Alter.
Ja, hab ich schon ein paar Tage gelesen.
Also da weiß ich auch nicht, was die immer machen.
Aber gut, ich mein, wenn man nur Faxgeräte gewohnt ist, kann sowas ja schon mal passieren.
Ja, ihr wisst ja, dass eigentlich bis 2020 Deutschland führend ist im Bereich von digitalen Ämtern und digitalen Behörden.
Wusstet ihr das eigentlich schon, dass wir da führend sind?
Also führend bedeutet...
Das ist aktuell gesehen, dass man die Sachen per Fax schickt.
Aber, aber laut eigener Aussage unserer Chefs sind wir führend in dem Bereich.
Weiß ich.
Ja, guck da, da hat er es gesagt.
Da hat er es gesagt.
Bis 2021 ist Deutschlands Verhandlung komplett digital, hat er 2017 erzählt.
Also, also mal ernsthaft, wer würde das nicht, wer hätte das nicht geglaubt?
Also ich war, ich war so, ich war komplett felsig.
Ich war so felsenfest davon überzeugt, das wird so, das wird so kommen, 2017.
Genauso wie wir auch bis 2018 50 Mbit für alle Haushalte haben.
Hätte ich auch nie dran gezweifelt, dass das passieren würde.
Also, es war, war mir klar, dass das, es wird alles eintreten, ja.
Das ist dumm, die Schwätze immer.
Nee, aber ansonsten ist die Woche, glaube ich, nicht allzu viel Spannendes passiert.
Ja, das, das stimmt wohl.
Das stimmt wohl.
Was halt witzig ist, gerade jetzt zu Corona-Zeiten wäre das echt praktisch gewesen,
wenn die ganzen Ämter digital ein bisschen besser aufgestellt wären
und sich nicht irgendwelche Daten per Fax, per Fax checken müssen.
Ihr müsst sich das mal überlegen, Fax, alter, Fax, das ist so alt.
Also die Tech, oh, ich muss die Musik einen kleinen Tick leiser machen.
Fax, das ist so alt, ich hab noch nicht mal mehr einen Fax,
also ich hab noch nicht mal die Möglichkeit, Faxe zu empfangen bei mir.
Also, ich hab theoretisch einen Multifunktionsdrucker, der, glaube ich, ich bin mir gar nicht sicher,
einen Anschluss hat für einen Fax, aber ich wüsste gar nicht, wo ich das reinstecken soll.
Da müsste ich den Drucker irgendwie an die Fritzbox anschließen oder so.
Wozu? Ich will überhaupt keine Faxe empfangen.
Ja, das ist alles gelabert, sieht man ja jetzt auch immer schön.
Es wird viel, wird viel gelabert.
Ihr wisst ja auch, dass, Moment, Moment, Light, Moment, Deutschland, Spiele,
Leitmarkt soll das hier, ja, also, es, Deutschland soll, soll ja auch Leitmarkt für Computerspiele,
also nicht wie Leiden, sondern wie Anführen, Leitmarkt soll Deutschland werden, was Computerspiele angeht.
Ich weiß nicht, in welcher, in welcher Fantasiewelt man sich da bewegt, ja, aber es soll so, soll so, soll so sein, ja.
Das stimmt nicht.
Mittlerweile auch digital Sachen unterschreiben und das zählt.
Sonst müsste ich ja alle, müsste ich ja jegliche NDA oder sonst was, müsste ich per Fax an irgendeinen Hersteller schicken oder so.
Ne, ne, du kannst das mittlerweile auch schon digital unterschreiben, das funktioniert.
Telefonanschluss.
Ja, theoretisch bräuchte, also du brauchst eine Telefonnummer, du brauchst eine Telefonnummer, es geht aber auch über VoIP, wenn das der Anbieter richtig macht.
Also wenn der Anbieter das nicht, Telekom und, und Vodafone und die ganzen, die haben ja,
die haben ja nur Voice-Over-IP, die haben ja auch gar kein richtiges Telefon mehr.
Ähm, und, wobei, doch, ich glaube, die Telekom bietet dir immer noch nen,
wenn du nur einen analogen Anschluss haben willst, machen die das immer noch,
aber spätestens ab dem nächsten Telekom-Cast, das ist VoIP, intern, ja, das funktioniert,
aber wozu, Fax, Fax ist halt echt Painschamp.
Gut, wenn du keine Telefonnummer hast, dann ist das natürlich mit, wird das mit Fax nix.
Um nochmal den Rap-Gott aus meinem, äh,
Arbeitsamt-Kurs von damals zu zitieren, machst du Faxen, mach ich dich platt mit Achsen.
Dann kriegt das Wort Fax mal eine ganz neue Bedeutung.
Welches deiner Repos ist eigentlich der Preis-Champ? Der Preis-Champ ist nirgendwo auf GitHub.
Den gibt's nicht.
Der Preis-Champ ist Closed-Source, Leute.
Dass ich das maximal monetarisieren kann.
Nur, dass ich überhaupt kein Geld dafür bezahle.
Äh, kein Geld dafür bekomme. Bezahlen tu ich dafür, aber ich bekomm kein Geld.
Ja, das mit der Trans-3070 und der 80, das ist das Problem,
dass der Crawler die Shops unterstützen muss und da haben die immer Probleme, deutsche Shops zu unterstützen.
Vielleicht gibt's das auch mittlerweile.
Und was ich hier auch lustig finde, ich hab mich ja schon mal drüber lustig gemacht,
ähm, dass sie gerade als, als besonders toll, was deutsche Games-Politik und sowas und deutsche Games angeht,
dass sie gerade den deutschen Computerspiele-Preis hervorheben, das find ich halt immer wieder lächerlich.
Der deutsche Computerspiele-Preis.
Der ist eines der unwichtigsten, unbedeutendsten und peinlichsten Veranstaltungen, die wir so zu bieten haben.
Es ist, es ist an, an, ja, heißer Luft kaum noch zu überbieten.
Ich hab's euch, ich hab mich ja letztens auch schon mal drüber ausgelassen, aber wisst ihr, was bestes Multiplayer-Game ist, laut dem deutschen Computerspiele-Preis?
Das beste Multiplayer-Game laut dem deutschen Computerspiele-Preis ist Animal Crossing.
Ich mein...
Allein schon, allein schon...
Allein schon ne, ne Nintendo-Game, was online gewinnt, äh, okay, Nintendo-Game allein ist jetzt vielleicht der Aussage,
noch nicht Aussage, aber ne Game, was den Fortschritt verliert, wenn jemand online aus der, aus der Session droppt.
Oder sowas, also...
Oder ne, du kannst, wie war das, ne, du kannst das Spiel nicht beenden, wenn ein Freund bei dir geht.
Total, es ist, es ist wir, also...
Wie um alles in der Welt kann Animal Crossing bestes Online-Game sein.
Dann hätten sie ja meinetwegen lieber...
Warzone oder irgendwas, irgendein ernstzunehmendes Online-Game, was 2020 rauskam, nehmen sollen.
Ja, zu Zeiten, als Crysis da was bekommen hat, war das in Ordnung.
Da hatten wir ja auch was.
Was, was gibt es aktuell für Games aus Deutschland?
Anno, Anno war mal aus Deutschland, ich weiß nicht, ob Anno noch aus Deutschland ist.
Crytek gibt's immer noch.
Die machen aber gerade ja nur Dings hier, dieses, äh, wie heißt das nochmal?
Dieses Wild West-Ding.
Äh, Hand? Hand.
Äh, sag mal, Hand Showdown oder so, genau, das, äh...
Ansonsten wüsste ich nicht, was, was Crytek...
Was macht eigentlich das Crytek-Moba, aus dem ist nie was geworden, ja?
Ja, das ist das Einzige, was mir so einfällt.
Ansonsten, was gibt's denn noch für größere, für größere deutsche Studios?
Okay, jetzt guck mal, German Game...
Okay.
Ja, 2000.
Okay, gucken wir mal, ob es die noch gibt, lul, weh.
Video-Industrie in Germany, okay.
Okay, wir haben dazu nicht mal einen deutschen Artikel auf Wikipedia.
Und, äh, der internationale Artikel über die Video-Games-Industrie in Deutschland ist schon ziemlich...
Es stimmt, die Gothic-Leute haben wir noch, aber da weiß ich nicht, ob es die überhaupt noch gibt.
Ach doch, die haben Alex gemacht letztens, ne?
Ich weiß aber nicht, ob die noch in Deutschland am Start sind.
Okay, Games Publisher.
Games Developer.
Games Developer of Germany, okay, wen haben wir da?
Äh, Ubisoft Blue Byte, das sind die Siedler-Leute, genau, Ubisoft Berlin, die...
Okay, die wusste ich nicht, dass sie mit an Far Cry machen.
Äh, Crysis, das, das wussten wir.
Ach, hier, die, äh, Adventure, Adventure-Stelz-Kram, genau.
Sagt mir jetzt grad, ich, ich, grad nix, aber ich, das ist auch eher nicht so meine...
Lords of the Fallen, war das nicht so ein, so ein Dark Souls-Klon?
Ja, doch.
Ah, ich erinnere mich wieder, ja.
Stimmt, die gibt's auch noch, die hätte ich jetzt ganz...
Oh, okay.
Ja, nee, Moment, die hab ich jetzt verwechselt.
Die gibt's auch noch, die hatten aber, glaub ich, nie bisher so den Riesen-Hit.
Äh, die Gothic-Leute gibt's, genau, die gibt's immer noch.
Äh...
Stimmt, die gibt's auch noch.
Die gibt's, die hab ich jetzt, da hab ich jetzt gar nicht...
Was haben, was haben die in letzter Zeit so gemacht?
Das...
Äh, nix.
Okay.
Ja.
Also, es hält sich, es hält sich durchaus in Grenzen.
Das war gar nicht so schlecht, nee, hab ich auch nicht gesagt.
Kann mich nur dran erinnern, dass das der Dark Souls...
Man kann's ja nicht Dark Souls...
Na doch, man kann's schon ein bisschen Dark Souls-Klon nennen.
Also, das sehr stark Dark Souls-inspirierte Game.
Das ist auch so eine Redewendung, die mich ja immer nervt, ne.
Sobald ein Spiel nicht easy as fuck ist, ist es sofort Dark Souls.
Keine Ahnung, irgendeiner baut einen Jump'n'Run, was nicht easy as fuck ist,
und da kommen dann die Ersten an, das Dark Souls der Jump'n'Runs.
Da krieg ich ja auch immer richtig Cringe-Anfälle, wenn ich die...
Das ist so ausgelutscht, diese Redewendung mittlerweile.
Die ist, die ist, glaube ich, so ausgelutscht, dass sie noch nicht mal Computerbild-Spiele...
Gibt's überhaupt noch Computerbild-Spiele verwendet?
Boah, gibt's da noch Computerbild-Spiele?
Tatsächlich, nee.
Gibt's die noch?
Es lesen immer noch eine Million Leute.
Okay.
Ja, Computerbild-Spiele gibt's noch.
Was, ich muss jetzt grad noch was anderes gucken.
Twitch.
Ich muss mal kurz gucken, was auf Twitch grad...
Ich hab's grad angesagt.
Spielen die Leute noch...
Sus...
Ähm...
Games.
Sag mal, warum sieht denn die Twitch-Seite so komisch aus auf einmal?
Kann ich nicht einfach...
Kann ich mir nicht mal einfach anzeigen lassen, was die meist gesehenen Spiele sind?
War das nicht sonst immer auf der Startseite so, dass man einfach die meist gesehenen Spiele hat?
Ah, hier.
LOL ist wieder vorne, GTA.
Warum ist denn Valorant auf einmal so weit oben?
Läuft da grad irgendwas?
Ah, da läuft er.
Da läuft irgendeine...
Irgendeine...
E-Sport-Stelz hier.
Koreanisches E-Sport...
E-Sport-Stelz.
Okay.
Weil ansonsten ist Valorant zwar gut dabei, aber nicht...
Nicht ganz vorne mit dabei.
Apex normalerweise auch nicht ganz, ganz oben.
Okay.
Da ist ein Stream allein schon mit 22k.
Alles klar.
Die Fortnite...
Was ich...
Was ich immer erstaunlich finde, dass ich...
Obwohl die Leute immer sagen, World of Warcraft übelst dead, dead und rip, wow und so.
Das scheint immer noch ganz gut zu laufen, ne?
Also...
Gut, ich meine, irgendwo muss Blizzard ja auch Geld verdienen.
Und wow ist halt gerade mit Abo-Modell so eine schöne Einnahmequelle, wo man weiß, das fällt nicht von heute auf morgen weg.
Der Scam-Train ist am Start.
Sorry.
Danke, Leute, für die ganzen Subs.
Ich muss mal kurz nachgucken, wer jetzt eigentlich alles am...
Ups.
Am Start ist.
Hier.
Game Up.
Dankeschön für den Prime-Sub.
14 Monate.
Das ist ja schon Massive Hyper-Subscription hier.
Der Eichler ist am Start.
23 Monate schon.
Dann haben wir Slimbeats ist am Start.
Und der Max, den hatten wir schon.
Nice, Leute, dass ihr alle wieder da seid.
Und natürlich...
Für den...
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Dass ihr beim Scam-Train mitmacht.
Schön, dass euch Twitch-Tipp gebildet hat, wieder euren Prime-Sub auszugeben.
18 Anzeige ist raus, Chainlore.
Dis-Abo.
Nee, wow, wow ist Monats-Abo.
Das ist nicht eine kleine User-Abo.
Das ist eine kleine User-User-Gruppe.
Wow hat ziemlich viele Spieler, immer noch.
Ich meine, ich veröffentliche keine Spielerzahlen mehr.
Aber du kannst davon ausgehen, das ist nicht von...
Das ist jetzt nicht innerhalb von ein paar Jahren von 9 Millionen auf 5.000 gedroppt oder so.
Also, ich hab keine Ahnung, wie viele Spieler Wow noch hat, aber es ist bestimmt ordentlich.
Und selbst wenn man mal ganz, ganz klein stapelt und sagen, keine Ahnung, die haben nur noch 500.000 Spieler, was wahrscheinlich viel zu wenig ist.
Es gibt noch deutlich mehr.
Und das irgendwie... Allein schon das gibt ja 5 Millionen im Monat, wenn die nur 10 Euro bezahlen.
Und es sind wahrscheinlich deutlich, deutlich mehr.
Also, Wow ist schon ordentlich.
Was mich, was mich... Genau, genau, was mich bei Wow...
Ich spiele, ich spiel's... Also, ich hab's nie richtig großartig gespielt, muss ich sagen.
Ich hab andere MMOs zwar durchgesuchtet, aber Wow hab ich nie so richtig reingefunden.
Natürlich hab ich ein bisschen gespielt, aber nie wirklich großartig.
Was mich an Wow so vom Beobachten ein bisschen nervt, ist, dass die wirklich...
...versuchen alles mögliche zu monetarisieren.
Also, die haben ein Monatsabo...
Du hast ein Ingame-Shop...
... und du hast Addons.
Also, du hast quasi alles...
Du hast Pay2Play, du hast Monatliche Gebühren...
Und du hast ein Shop-Ingame-Micro-Transactions.
Also, die haben wirklich alles monetarisiert, was geht.
Und das finde ich übrigens nicht gut,
weil ich bin der Meinung...
Weil ich bin der Meinung...
gerade spiele, ich propagiere ja
selbst immer, ich sag, für MMOs
ist eigentlich das beste Modell
monatliche Subscription.
Oder meinetwegen Pay-to-Play,
aber, also, man
kauft ein Spiel, also man kauft ein Add-on, kann ja so viel
spielen, aber
ich
sag ja immer, Monthly Subscription,
Monthly Fee ist so das beste für MMOs,
allerdings nicht,
wenn du dann alles andere auch noch dazu
machst. Was, Add-ons?
Natürlich sind Add-ons von Blizzard.
Ich meine nicht,
ich meine jetzt nicht
irgendwelche UI-Add-ons, ich meine
sowas wie, äh,
was war das letzte WoW-Add-on, was rausgekommen ist?
Shadowlands. Das musst du immer noch kaufen,
oder? Da reicht keine monatliche
Gebühr.
Du bezahlst Monatgebühr, du musst
Add-ons kaufen, und
dann hast du noch einen
Microtransaction-Store. Also,
die monetarisieren wirklich alles, was
irgendwie geht.
Das finde ich auch
leicht, leicht,
übrigens.
Übertrieben bei Blizzard, zumindest bei WoW.
Fazit zu Nextcloud 22,
ja, es hat sich in einigen Bereichen
verbessert, die Apps sind immer noch ziemlich basic,
und ich werde wahrscheinlich
kein großer Nextcloud-Fan werden.
Genau, genau.
Also, die Kombination verstehe ich,
das war ja eigentlich früher auch normal.
Du hast den MMO, das hat monatlich
gekostet, okay, da kannst du
sagen, ja, die monatlichen Kosten
ist halt super
für den Entwickler, der kann seine Leute
bezahlen, der kann
seinen Support bezahlen, der kann seine Admins bezahlen,
seine Entwickler bezahlen, Serverkosten bezahlen
und das Spiel quasi
pflegen, erweitern, sonst wie.
Und dann setzt man sich halt auch nebenbei noch
ran mit einem eigenen Team und macht eine
Expansion, die man verkauft
wie ein extra Game.
Das verstehe ich, das finde ich auch
in Ordnung, was ich aber auch richtig
assi finde, ist, dass du da noch anfängst mit
irgendwelchen Microtransaction-Geschichten.
Level-Boost übrigens, das in Kombination, das ist
ein absolutes Unding.
Plan ist heute, wir gucken,
das was wir immer sonntags morgens machen,
ich schwätze ein bisschen, wir gucken Videos dabei,
ähm, das ist ein
absolutes Unding, gerade, gerade
Level-Boosts, also wenn man ein
Pay-to, äh, äh, äh, tja,
ähm, warte mal, wie soll man das jetzt nennen,
ein, ein, ein, äh,
Pay-to-Play mit Subscription-Modell hat,
dann musst du, dann,
aus meiner Sicht ist das Spiel sonst nicht
spielenswert, dann musst du sicherstellen,
dass das Spiel so
designed ist und so,
ähm, erst mal so optimiert ist,
dass es darauf
ausgelegt ist, dass du ohne
zusätzliche Hilfe die
Dinger in-Game erreichen kannst,
mit dem nötigen
Einsatz-Zeitaufwand, wie die Spiele-Designer
sich das gedacht haben. Das heißt,
wenn man sagt, okay, jeder, der das,
jeder, der die Monatsgebühr bezahlt,
sollte in-Game die gleichen
Möglichkeiten haben und die gleichen Chancen
haben und nicht noch
zusätzlich durch Microtransactions den ganzen
Kram boosten lassen, weil sonst stellst du das
ganze Modell irgendwie, ich meine, ich weiß,
es ist ja offensichtlich, dass es funktioniert,
sonst stellt sich aus meiner Sicht die Frage,
warum überhaupt?
Ja, das finde ich halt kacke.
Und gerade bei WoW Classic,
wo ja,
wo ja, äh, so die
Oldschool-Experience
im Vordergrund stehen soll,
mit, mit Leveln und
Social-Aspekt, ist es jetzt natürlich noch doppelt
bescheuert, Level-Boost zu machen.
Äh, also ich kann nur, ich kann nicht
von World of Warcraft reden, ich kann bloß
zum Beispiel von Dark Age of Camelot
spielen, äh, reden, was ich ja über 10,
ja, gespielt habe. Die GMs, die wurden
beschissen bezahlt, das, das, das
weiß man mittlerweile, die wurden
beschissen bezahlt, der, ähm,
der
Europa-Publisher war ein richtig großer Kacklan,
aber die GMs
haben sich abends von
daheim oder nachts von
daheim teilweise eingeloggt, und
ich weiß nicht, ob die das jemals bezahlt bekommen haben,
äh, hoffe ich mal zumindest, eingeloggt,
ähm,
um Leute aus einem verbackenen Dungeon
rauszuteleportieren und sowas.
Also,
zumindest da kann ich sagen, also,
es gibt schon GMs mit,
mit, wie sagt man, mit Leib und Seele,
die wirklich
bis zum Umfallen game-mastern.
Tribunon,
20 Monate, huge subscription
hier. IQ++++
für den Chat.
Der Scam-Train ist auf Level 2, Leute, wir haben noch eine Minute
Zeit, den Scam-Train voll zu machen.
Wenn der Scam-Train voll ist,
dann fangen wir auch an, Videos zu gucken, und ich labere euch
nicht weiter voll. Wobei, vielleicht sind die,
die Leute auch gerade da, weil ich sie, man, man, man
weiß nicht.
Ja. Ja, das finde ich
nicht gut.
Auch als Spieler finde ich den Story
in-game nicht, was?
Den Store meinst du wahrscheinlich, ne?
Ja, da siehst du ja, du hast
dir das Problem ja schon selbst beantwortet.
Das,
das ist, das ist eines der Probleme,
die dadurch auftreten. Ja gut,
dass es Mounts, Pets und Kosmetik-Shit
gibt, finde ich auch schlimm,
weil,
da, man muss mal überlegen, was so ein MMO mit
ausmacht. Character Customization
ist eines
der zentralen, oder, oder,
Charakter Upgrade und Customization
ist eines der zentralen
Punkte eines MMOs.
Wenn ich mir das kaufen kann,
stelle ich quasi, stelle ich quasi
in Frage, warum mache ich den Content überhaupt?
Warum soll ich den Content machen,
wenn ich mir das Mount im Shop kaufen kann?
Warum soll ich einen halben Monat
grinden für einen One-Time
Event Mount, wenn ich mir das
Mount ein halbes Jahr später auch für 5 Euro
oder, na gut, es sind Blizzard-Preise, für 20 Euro
im Shop kaufen kann? Das ist
lächerlich. Der Kram, der muss,
wenn das, wenn das Monthly-Fee ist
und wenn das
Pay-to-Play ist, dann muss das
mit dem, da muss das mit dem gleichen
In-Game-Aufwand für alle Leute verbunden
sein, ohne Abkürzung durch
den Shop. Und wenn ich eben nur
37-jähriger Boomer bin,
der arbeiten gehen muss, Familie
hat und nur eine Stunde
am Tag oder, keine Ahnung, nur mal 4 Stunden am
Wochenende spielen kann, dann muss
ich halt damit leben,
dass ich nicht in High-End-Tier-Rüstung
in der Hauptstadt rumposen kann.
Dann hab ich halt Pech.
Dann können halt, äh,
keine Ahnung, 20-jährige
Harzer, die den ganzen Tag 24-7
haben, dann halt In-Game mehr.
So ist es halt. Aber so muss das auch
sein. So, das ist meine Meinung
dazu. Bounty20,
danke schön für den Prime-Sub.
Übrigens, bei Blizzard, die haben ja noch mehr,
die haben ja noch deutlich mehr verkackt. Könnt ihr euch noch,
wie gesagt, ich bin bei World of Warcraft
nur so stiller an der Seitenlinie
verfolger, könnt ihr euch noch an dieses
World of Warcraft-Turnier erinnern, wo die
Community, wo die Community-technisch
Geld gesammelt haben
und haben gesagt, hey, wir machen jetzt einen Shop
für, äh, äh,
keine Ahnung, Mounts, sonst wie was und ein Teil
davon geht an so einen Community
oder BlizzCon war das sogar, so ein BlizzCon
PvP-Turnier und
dass wir quasi
die, die, die Turnierpreise
erhöhen können.
Kann sich da noch jemand,
kann sich da noch jemand dran erinnern? Und wo alle
davon ausgegangen sind, ja, okay,
man supportet quasi jetzt mit, mit
Shop-Käufen das nächste BlizzCon
PvP-Turnier, aber Blizzard
bezahlt auch noch
ihr normales Preisgeld. So,
und die Leute haben wie verrückt im Shop eingekauft,
ich hoffe, ich geb das jetzt halbwegs korrekt wieder,
das war ein paar Jahre her, und dann hat Blizzard
gesagt zur BlizzCon, ach ja gut,
wir haben ja jetzt ja so viel Geld eingesammelt
durch die Shop-Verkäufe,
äh, Shop-Verkäufe, wir, äh,
geben kein normales Preisgeld mehr, muss ich das mal
auf der Zunge zergehen lassen. Ein PvP-Turnier
von ihrem Game auf ihrer hauseigenen
Messe bekommt kein Preisgeld von Blizzard
selbst für die Gewinner. Was ist denn das
für lächerliche Aktion? Und das,
ja, willst du
den Chat verkaufen?
Warum nicht? Der Chat ist
so high IQ, da könnte man eigentlich mal zu Geld machen.
Was macht der 3D-Drucker zur Zeit?
Der ist aus.
Ja, das ist ja noch schlimmer.
Das ist ja noch dümmer.
Dass du, dass du exklusive
Paywall-Geschichten hast. Das ist ja noch, das ist ja noch schlimmer.
Wenn ich
monthly fee bezahle, plus pay-to-play
add-on, dann sollte ich eben auch Zugriff
haben durch Spielen auf alles, was das Game
zu bieten hat. Ja, richtig.
Die sind selber dran schuld, dass
WoW auf dem absteigenden Ast ist.
Man kann
davon abgehen, und wenn jetzt jemand sagt, World of Warcraft
ist nicht auf dem absteigenden Ast,
das kann man,
kann man ja sehen, wie man will,
aber allein schon der Fakt,
dass Blizzard vor ein paar Jahren
aufgehört hat, Spielerzahlen zu veröffentlichen,
also immer, immer,
wenn, wenn ein Unternehmen,
was vorher Spielerzahlen veröffentlicht hat,
auf einmal aus irgendwelchen fadenscheinigen
Gründen sagt, die veröffentlichen keine Spielerzahlen mehr,
da hat das immer damit was
zu tun, dass die Zahlen nicht so geil aussehen,
wie man das gerne hätte, oder wie man da
irgendwelchen Investoren quasi
Dollarzeichen in die Augen bringen kann.
Immer. Das heißt, du kannst davon
ausgehen, sobald
irgendjemand Zahlen veröffentlicht,
die immer nach oben gehen,
und sich feiert, und auf einmal sagt er,
ich veröffentliche keine Zahlen mehr,
dann kannst du von auf, dann kannst du
so sicher wie das Arm in der Kirche,
davon ausgehen, dass die Zahlen
aktuell nicht mehr stonksen, sondern
not stonk sind.
Dota kenne ich mich nicht aus.
Aber Dota hat auch keine
monatliche Gebühr.
Ja, hat der Chat doch.
Also ich bin mir sicher,
der Chat war sicherlich maßgeblich
am Amazon Basic Corona
Impfstoff beteiligt.
Es ist doch nicht, es kommt demnächst.
Kennst du dich mit Frauen aus?
Ja, wir sind hier bekannt dafür,
dass, also gerade der Chat,
so hier der Chat aus 24-7
Hackerman-Informatiker-Leuten, das ist natürlich bekannt
für, dass wir hier
Next-Level-Dating-Tipps immer raushauen.
Wo ist denn der Sibaro?
Der kennt sich aus.
Den brauchen wir jetzt.
Schaust du eigentlich Serien oder so, wenn ja, was?
Ja. Ja.
Lass mal überlegen, was habe ich denn zuletzt
geguckt?
Also nicht so oft, aber
was habe ich denn zuletzt geguckt?
Ich muss mich immer wieder an Mr. Robot erinnern, wo ich die erste
halbe Staffel mega geil fand und danach kacke.
Upload, Upload
habe ich geguckt, ja. Fand ich eigentlich
ganz cool, auch wenn es am Ende die letzten paar
Folgen wieder nachgelassen hat.
Ich überlege gerade, was war denn das letzte an Serien,
was ich geguckt habe? Also das letzte neue.
Ich gucke mal kurz,
ich gucke mal kurz, Amazon, zack, zack, Amazon.
Your Orders.
Ah ne, Moment.
Moment, watch.
Amazon Prime Video.
Wirst du dir die zweite Witcher-Staffel
anschauen? Wahrscheinlich, auch wenn
ich die erste Witcher-Staffel nur
okay fand.
Okay, aha, hier. Also.
Serious.
Originals, Alter.
Warum ist eigentlich die Amazon,
die Amazon Video App mittlerweile
so unübersichtlich?
Wo zum Teufel sind Originals?
Warum kann man da nicht mal nach
Serien filtern? Das ging doch immer.
Hm.
Verwirrend.
Was machen die denn mit der App?
Was ich immer mal wieder gucke,
ein paar Folgen ist Dr. House, aber das ist jetzt ja nicht
wirklich neu. Tja.
Ich kann es euch nicht sagen, weil
die Amazon,
die Amazon Video App ist einfach kacke.
Heck, wait.
Ja, noch nicht, ne?
Dann nicht.
So, fangen wir mal an.
Gucken wir mal ein paar YouTube-Videos.
Ja, also das Amazon, was, was,
das Amazon... Wisst ihr, wisst ihr, was ich auch richtig Müll finde?
Amazon, ähm,
äh, wie heißt das?
Music Web Player.
Ich muss, ich muss ja mal ein Screenshot von raussuchen.
Warte mal.
Gibt's da irgendwie einen schönen Screenshot von?
Ja.
Nee, nicht wirklich.
Die haben's, ja doch, hier.
Also, die haben's geschafft
bei,
bei Amazon, nee, das ist,
das ist nicht das Neue.
Das ist irgendeine Mac-Geschichte. Zumindest, die haben's,
Die haben es ernsthaft geschafft, dass man, man kann hier unten normalerweise die Lautstärke regeln bei Amazon Video.
Und die haben es ernsthaft geschafft, einen Musikplayer zu machen, wo man die Lautstärke nicht richtig regeln kann.
Das ist bescheuert. Normalerweise ist doch jemand ein Knopf, um die Lautstärke zu regeln.
Egal, wer es kennt, kennt das UI.
Die haben es wirklich geschafft, einen Player zu machen, wo man die Lautstärke nicht richtig regeln kann.
Es hat zwar einen Knopf, um die Lautstärke zu regeln, aber du kannst die Lautstärke nicht in Prozent korrekt regeln.
Du kannst sie immer nur so in 10% Schritten regeln.
Das heißt, die Musik ist entweder zu laut oder zu leise.
Ich weiß nicht, ob da irgendeiner bei Amazon da gesessen hat, hat sich gedacht, ach ne, ach ne, also das ist ja User nicht zuzumuten.
Die User sind bestimmt zu dumm, die Lautstärke richtig einzustellen.
Den müssen wir das abnehmen und machen die Lautstärke jetzt nur noch in 10er Schritten.
Dann hast du das Problem, dass du deine...
...Playlist nicht mehr richtig sortieren kannst.
Also geht schon, aber ist eklig im Vergleich zu früher.
Also es ist keine Ahnung.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was die ganzen UI-Designer eigentlich machen, alle.
Leuchtet mir nicht ein.
Chinesische Miner verkaufen Grafikkarten zu Sportpreisen.
Ja, habe ich ja gerade gesagt.
Das ist zur Zeit, wenn man in China wohnt, ist es eine super Gelegenheit, eine Grafikkarte zu bekommen.
Ja, das Netflix-UI ist besser, aber ich mache das immer so.
Ich habe halt Prime und ich habe mal diese Prime-Video-Geschichte mal dazu geholt.
Netflix gucke ich mir immer nur...
Netflix mache ich mir immer irgendein Test-Abo, wenn ich mal was gucken will.
Die Witcher-Serie habe ich auch mit einem Test-Abo geguckt.
Wenn ich das nächste Mal wieder was auf Netflix gucken will, mache ich mir einfach nur wieder ein Test-Abo.
So hat kein Problem. Funktioniert.
Ja, das stimmt.
Wobei das vom Konzept her gar nicht mal so weit an der Realität vorbei geht, wenn man ein bisschen weiter denkt in ein paar Jahren, ja.
Also natürlich das, was sie da drinnen gezeigt haben, war natürlich eher nicht realistisch.
Alexa kann auch nur in 10er-Schritten.
Ja, da haben die sich gedacht, wenn Alexa das nur in 10er-Schritten kann, dann brauche ich das in einem Webplayer mit Maus- und Tastaturbedienung auch.
Wie, es gibt keine Test-Abos mehr?
Kann doch nicht sein.
Ich habe, wie gesagt, die letzte Witcher-Serie habe ich im Test-Abo geguckt.
Es gibt keine Test-Abos mehr?
Was soll das?
Anzeige ist raus.
Es gibt keinen Test, das ist aber kacke.
Ansonsten bezahle ich es einen Monat, ja.
Also wie gesagt, die letzte Witcher-Serie habe ich über einen Test-Abo geguckt.
Wie machst du das mit der Telefonnummer?
Ja, tja, wird nicht verraten.
Also, kennst du die Programmiersprache OpenEdge-Abel?
OpenEdge-Abel?
Ne, kenne ich nicht.
Oh, zeig mal her.
Äh, hat da einer schlecht geschlafen und von Pascal geträumt oder was?
Was soll das?
Was gibt das, wenn es fertig ist?
Damit machst du...
Damit machst du Big Stonks?
Ich weiß ja nicht.
Und warum sollte man das verwenden?
Boah.
Ne, kenne ich nicht.
Kenne ich nicht.
Ich wüsste auch nicht, wofür das...
Oh, hier.
Stonks.
Keine Ahnung.
Ja.
Ja, so kann ich es mir jetzt vorstellen.
Ja, feels bad, man.
So, schauen wir uns mal an.
Was gucken wir uns denn auf YouTube jetzt an?
Komm, wir lassen uns als erstes mal wieder von Level Cap G-Baden.
Das muss jetzt sein.
Der wöchentliche Level Cap G-Bade.
Ja, das habe ich mitbekommen.
Das mit den Cheats habe ich mitbekommen, da wollte ich auch ein Video drüber machen.
Ja.
Das ist ein Update für Call of Duty ist fast hier und viel mehr.
Vorher diese Woche haben wir einen neuen Art von Cheating für Konsolegames, der Maschinenlernung verwendet, um einen Aimbot zu jedem Spiel zu geben.
Ja.
Es ist...
Das ist eigentlich eine gute Idee und ich wundere mich, dass das nicht früher schon jemand gemacht hat.
Der Vorteil davon ist, also, nur mal so, also, falls es jetzt zu schnell war, ich erkläre nochmal kurz, wie das funktioniert.
Also, du greifst den...
Du greifst den Video-Output mit irgendeiner Capture-Card ab, dann hast du auf deinem PC eine Software, die das ganze Bild analysiert, analysiert, wo sind Gegner und daraus errechnet ist Controllerbewegung und den Controller-Input schickst du dann wieder an die Konsole.
Also, es ist für die Konsole nicht sichtbar, dass du, dass das nicht du bist, sondern irgendwie eine Software gesteuert ist.
Ist eigentlich ziemlich Big Brain, die Idee.
Ist jetzt aber auch jetzt nichts bahnbrechend Neues, deswegen wundert es mich, dass man noch nicht auf die Idee gekommen ist.
Vorher das zu machen.
Und das Coole daran ist, dass du theoretisch das erweitern kannst auf jedes Spiel.
Du musst halt nur die passende AI anbieten dafür oder trainieren.
Was heißt nur in Anführungsstrichen, also einfach ist das nicht.
Aber du kannst das theoretisch erweitern für jedes Spiel.
Das heißt, du kannst Cheats basteln für was weiß ich, für Call of Duty, für GTA, für alles mögliche und das alles mit der gleichen Software.
Also, das ist schon wirklich Next Level Big Brain, Alter, der Kram.
Ohne Scheiß.
Zumindest, es ist nicht zu erkennen für die Konsole, weil es läuft ja nichts.
Also, es ist weder für ein PS, also, ne.
Wenn du, normalerweise hast du zwei Möglichkeiten, Cheats zu erkennen.
Entweder du erkennst, dass der, also du erkennst den Cheat direkt, dass der läuft.
Sagen wir mal, du cheatest den Battlefield oder Counter-Strike oder sonst wie.
Und Steam guckt im Hintergrund.
Läuft irgendwie ein Programm, läuft ein Programm mit spezieller Signatur, was auch immer.
Das heißt, du weißt direkt nach dem Spieler, dass der den Cheat gerade ausführt.
Oder, dass irgendwas auf sich in dein Game reingehuckt hat oder was auch immer.
Also, sprich, du weißt den Cheat direkt nach.
Das ist natürlich die beste Variante.
Da kannst du nämlich direkt sagen, Easy Life, Bann.
So, die nächste Variante ist, bei solchen Cheats, die sind ja nicht zu erkennen.
Also, du kannst ja solche Cheats auf der Konsole nicht erkennen.
Weil auf der Konsole selbst nichts.
Läuft, was irgendwie Anhaltspunkte bieten wird, dass gecheatet wird.
Also, die Konsole, die gibt das Bild aus und bekommt Controller-Input.
Die Konsole bekommt absolut gar nichts, ähm, gar nichts mit davon.
So, was du jetzt aber machen kannst, du kannst das Ganze natürlich indirekt nachweisen.
Zum Beispiel über Statistik, ja.
Wie schnell ist der Typ on target?
Wie genau ist der on target?
Was ist seine Hitrate im Vergleich zu den besten Spielern der Welt?
Etc.
Es gibt, kannst du verschiedene Sachen machen.
Darauf kannst du natürlich wieder deine eigene Anti-Cheat-AI trainieren.
Was dann im Endeffekt darauf rausläuft, dass Cheat-AI vs. Anti-Cheat-AI am Start ist, ja.
Und das wird noch witzig, aber direkt nachweisen kannst du es nicht.
Ich muss mal kurz die Musik wieder ausmachen.
In Rainbow Six, was?
In Rainbow Six werden mittlerweile Spieler wegen einer zu hohen Headshot-Rate gebannt, ob sie cheaten oder nicht.
Ja, das ist leider die Früchte, die das Ganze so trägt.
Sobald du den Kram nicht mehr direkt nachweisen kannst, wird es halt immer mehr False-Positives geben.
Also du wirst halt immer mehr Leute bannen, weil sie halt eine zu gute Statistik haben.
Deswegen ist das, das ist ein echt schwieriges Gebiet und ich glaube aber, dass es die nächsten Jahre über besser wird.
Ich glaube, dass umso besser das trainiert wird, umso mehr Entwicklung da reinfließt, umso besser wird das Ganze.
Aber es wird nie...
Es wird dann nie perfekt werden.
Ich meine, am besten ist halt, wenn du den Cheat direkt nachweisen kannst, aber das wird bei sowas halt nicht funktionieren.
Ja.
Einfach die Cheat-AI anhand von Pro-Playern trainieren, um legit zu wirken.
Na, so einfach ist das nicht.
So einfach ist das nicht.
Also du kannst jetzt so eine Cheat-AI nicht programmieren, zu spielen wie ein Pro-Player.
Du kannst sie vielleicht trainieren, die Geschwindigkeit im Aim oder in irgendeiner Art und Weise irgendwie von einem Pro-Player nachzuahmen.
Aber ein Pro-Player hat ja noch andere Sachen.
Ja, also das...
Was er denkt während dem Game.
Also das so zu trainieren wird schwierig.
Das siehst du zum Beispiel auch daran.
Es gibt ja mittlerweile League of Legends-Bots, wo auch sogar Pro-Gamer sagen, dass es saumäßig schwierig ist, dagegen zu spielen und fast nicht mehr möglich ist, zu gewinnen.
Aber die AI spielt halt null wie andere Pro-Player.
Die spielt komplett anders.
Und jeder Pro kann dir quasi sagen, das ist eine AI, die da spielt.
Und...
Und sie können trotzdem nicht dagegen gewinnen.
Nein, ich meine nicht Skripts.
Ich meine nicht Skripts.
Es gab mal so einen Versuch, dass man wirklich...
Ich glaube...
Ich weiß nicht, ob es von Google war.
Es gab wirklich einen LOL-AI-Bot im größeren Stil.
Es kann auch sein, dass es in Dota war.
Wo man wirklich trainiert hat, den Bot spielen zu lassen.
Jetzt nicht ein Spiel mit einem Spieler zu unterstützen, mit irgendwelchen Autobys oder was auch immer.
Sondern dass es wirklich...
Autonom spielt mit dem, was ihm das Spiel liefert.
Eine StarCraft-AI, die gab es auch.
Die gab es auch.
Da weiß ich aber nicht, wie gut die war.
Die hat wahrscheinlich auch alles geownt.
Nee, aber es gab auch eine LOL-Geschichte.
Und...
Oder war es StarCraft?
Nee, ich glaube, es war LOL.
Und die Pro-Player haben dazu gesagt, dass sie sofort erkannt haben, was die AI ist und was nicht.
Oder Dota.
Die Dota-Spieler haben sofort erkannt, was AI ist und was nicht.
Aber sie hatten quasi keine Chance zu gewinnen.
Das Ding ist halt...
Von den Mechanics her absolut perfekt.
Also wenn du...
Es gibt ja...
Ich kenne mich mit LOL und Dota nicht so gut aus.
Aber ich weiß, dass es da irgendwelche High-Level-Mechaniken gibt.
So nach dem Motto, irgendwelche Animationen canceln, links-rechts steppen.
Dass dein Boomerang schneller zurückkommt und solche Dinger.
Also da gibt es jede Menge Moves, die du quasi als Pro ausführst, während du das Spiel normal spielst.
Das du aber selbst auf absolutem Pro-Level nicht perfekt hinkriegst.
Also du lässt dann immer...
Immer mal triffst du den richtigen Frame fürs Animation-Canceling nicht oder was auch immer.
Und das Problem hast du halt als AI nicht.
Der spielt seinen Charakter Mechanic-technisch hundertprozentig einfach perfekt.
Das ist das, was du als Pro nicht hinkriegst.
Und selbst wenn du vielleicht die Big-Brain-Moves machen könntest,
ist das Ding dir Economy-mäßig schon immer ein Stück dann voraus.
Also es ist halt...
Es ist halt...
Ein komplett anderes Spiel, wie wenn das jetzt irgendein Mensch wäre, der das spielen würde.
Und trotz...
Also die Pros können dir sofort sagen, ob das eine AI...
Also die Pros können dir sofort sagen, ob das eine AI ist oder nicht.
Zumindest stand das damals in dem Artikel drin.
Also die Pros gesagt haben, sie können sofort erkennen, dass das eine AI ist.
Aber sie konnten halt nicht gewinnen dagegen.
Oder was weiß ich, eins von zehn Games oder so.
So, gucken wir mal.
Witt weiter.
Es gibt ja auch diesen Hack, sorry, das ist schon wieder unterbrechend.
Es gibt ja auch diese Geschichte mit, dass man das am PC probiert.
Weiß nicht, ob ihr das mitbekommen habt,
dass...
Ähm...
Es ein...
Moment.
Dass es letztens ein Cheatsystem gab für einen PC,
der Maus- und Tastatur-Inputs simuliert hat.
Und die haben das folgendermaßen gemacht.
Die haben eine PCI-Express-Karte eingebaut in den Rechner.
PCI-Express-Karten, Hardware, hat Zugriff auf den Arbeitsspeicher.
Und das haben die getan, glaube ich, als Netzwerkkarte,
obwohl es gar keine Netzwerkkarte war.
Also die haben eine PCI-Express-Hardware-Karte eingebaut,
die hat Zugriff auf den Arbeitsspeicher.
Und das haben die getan, glaube ich, als Netzwerkkarte, obwohl es gar keine Netzwerkkarte war.
Also die haben eine PCI-Express-Hardware-Karte eingebaut,
die Zugriff auf den Arbeitsspeicher hatte.
Die hat quasi den Arbeitsspeicher gescannt,
geguckt, wo die wichtigen Daten von den Games stehen.
Das Game hat das nicht gemerkt,
weil halt nichts an Software auf dem Rechner läuft,
sondern dass halt eine Hardware-Karte als Netzwerkkarte getarnt war.
Die hat den RAM ausgelesen vom Game,
hat dann die wichtigen Daten extrahiert,
an einen Microcontroller geschickt,
und der Microcontroller hat dann Maus und Tastatur bedient.
Das war quasi alles, was sie hatten.
Das war quasi ein nicht wirklich erkennbarer Cheat auf dem PC,
weil du es nicht direkt nachweisen kannst in Form von
ich erkenne eine Software, ich kenne einen Cheat, der im Hintergrund läuft.
Sowas kannst du nur nachweisen über irgendwelche Statistiken oder sowas.
Also du kannst es nicht mehr direkt nachweisen.
Mittlerweile, gut, man könnte natürlich sagen,
ja gut, warum haben die nicht die Hardware im Rechner erkannt?
Naja, das ist gar nicht so einfach.
Das Ding hat sich getarnt als Netzwerkkarte.
Du kannst jetzt schlecht Leute mit einer Netzwerkkarte
im Rechner bannen.
Du kannst sagen, okay, Netzwerkkarten mit diesem Hersteller,
mit dieser MAC-Adresse werden gebannt,
okay, das kannst du machen,
aber dann ändert das der Hersteller einfach.
Also ein Hardwarehersteller kann ja reinschreiben, was er lustig ist.
Das ist kein großartiges Problem.
Und du kannst ja schlecht Leute bannen dafür,
dass sie Hardware im PCI-Express-Slot stecken haben.
Das ist das Normalste von der Welt,
Hardware im PCI-Express-Slot zu haben.
Die sollte aber nicht direkten Zugriff auf allen Speichern haben.
Ich muss dir ehrlich sagen,
ich habe keine Ahnung, wie das unter Windows genau läuft.
Aber es war wohl möglich.
Sonst hätte der ganze Cheat nicht funktioniert.
Das auf Hardware-Ebene, wie das treibertechnisch aussieht,
absolut keine Ahnung.
Weiß ich nicht.
Mit Stadia wäre das nicht passiert.
Doch, klar, mit Stadia.
Das ist ja gerade der Witz da,
daran, sowas kannst du auf jeder Plattform machen.
Also sobald du nur noch den Output brauchst
und den Input hinschickst,
ist es komplett plattformunabhängig.
Der Cheat nimmt aktuell,
natürlich würde das mit Stadia funktionieren,
der Cheat nimmt aktuell das Output-Signal von der Konsole,
errechnet, welchen Input er machen muss
für einen Headshot und schickt den Input dahin.
Das funktioniert mit der Konsole genauso wie mit Stadia.
So, jetzt aber.
Hatten ihre Videos und Ads von Activision gedreht?
Ja, gut.
Die Chinesen kennen ja gar keinen Spaß mehr.
Da kommst du ja sogar ein Knast als Cheat-Hersteller.
Das können die ja, glaube ich, gar nicht so einfach.
Ich bin mir nicht mal sicher, ob das verboten ist, ehrlich gesagt.
Die greifen nicht in das Spiel ein,
die greifen nicht irgendwie in Rechte von Activision ein.
Ich kann mir nicht stellen, dass das verboten ist.
Ich wüsste nicht gegen,
ich meine, keine Rechtsberatung, bla bla bla,
ich habe mir da nicht vorgebildet, was das angeht,
aber ich wüsste nicht, gegen was das verstoßen sollte,
wenn du den Output abgreifst,
von einem externen System verarbeiten lässt
und dann über den normalen Input wieder Sachen an die Konsole...
Also, es ist...
Es ist fragwürdig, ob das Herstellen solcher Cheats wirklich illegal ist.
Was du sagen könntest, ist natürlich,
das Benutzen dieser Cheats ist insofern gegen die TOS
und du kannst die Leute bannen, wenn du sie dann merkst,
wenn du es dann feststellst.
Das wirst du auf jeden Fall machen können,
aber rechtlich belangend, so einen Cheat-Hersteller,
das stelle ich mir äußerst schwierig vor.
Es gibt mehrere Beispiele für Anti-Cheats,
die Leute mit ähnlichen Methoden fangen.
Das Detekten von Maschinen-assistierter Auto-Aim
und Injektierter Inputs ist nichts Neues für Game-Developer,
selbst auf Konsolen.
Also, wenn Activision oder andere Entwickler
keine legalen Aktionen gegen diese Art von Cheats nehmen,
gibt es immer noch die Hoffnung,
dass sie die Leute fangen können, die sie benutzen.
Wenn du jetzt Fußball spielst und deine Schuhe tunest,
dann verstößt du vielleicht gegen die Regeln
von deinem Verein oder der Liga, in der du spielst,
aber die Fans werden dich nicht dafür verklagen können.
Die können dich bannen, dass du nie wieder spielen kannst,
wenn sie dich erwischen.
Das ist das Gleiche, was Activision auch machen kann.
Activision kann dich bannen, wenn sie dich erwischen
und sagen, du darfst dieses Spiel
auf diesem Account nie wieder spielen.
Das ist okay.
Aber die können dich nicht verklagen in Form von,
keine Ahnung, ich krieg jetzt von dir 50.000 Euro.
Dann könnt ihr es probieren,
aber ich glaube nicht, dass es klappt.
Sellout.
Exzellent, Sellout.
Next.
Redacted Mode.
Ja.
Das haben wir schon vermutet.
Nice.
Ja.
Ja, da bin ich mal gespannt. Ich hoffe, da darf ich mitmachen beim Closed Technical Test.
Haben sie es jetzt eigentlich geschafft, dass man seine Mitspieler wieder sieht?
Gut, Ravensoft hat jetzt ja sich nicht mit Ruhm beklickert die letzten Monate über.
Was? Das gibt's noch?
Das gibt's noch?
Null.
Also, die haben es so mega verkackt.
Das Game, das haben die angekündigt vor, keine Ahnung, fünf Jahren oder so.
Ich hab mir sogar auch mal damals Early Access mal angucken wollen.
Das kam zu einer Zeit, wo die Leute richtig, wie sagen wir so, gelächzt haben nach einem modernen Combat Battlefield.
Und da haben die das angekündigt und haben gesagt, sie machen sowas in der Regel.
Was natürlich viele Battlefield-Fans gefreut hat und gesagt haben, cool, es muss ja nicht unbedingt ein Battlefield von DICE sein.
Es kann ja auch ein Battlefield von einem anderen Hersteller sein.
Und jetzt haben die einfach fünf Jahre lang nichts gemacht.
Und jetzt, in dem Jahr, wo Battlefield 2042 rauskommt, jetzt wollen sie ein Update bringen?
Die haben die Zeit einfach komplett verschlafen.
Das kannst du jetzt echt nicht in den Ernst sein.
Die Entwickler haben einige bedeutende Verbesserungen zu der Bewegung und Weaponoptik des Spiels.
Es wird interessant sein, ob World War 3 in der Schattel des Battlefield 2042 existieren kann.
World War 3 war gefeuert, als Battlefield-Versammlung, während DICE auf historische Schüsse konzentriert war.
Aber mit 2042 als moderner Militär-FPS scheint es nicht so zu sein, dass es viel Raum gibt, um beide Spiele zu koexistieren.
Neun Minuten neuer Deathloop-Gameplay wurden während des neuesten PlayStation-State-of-Play-Events veröffentlicht.
Das Spiel verbindet die Stealth- und Kampfmechaniken des Spiels.
Es gibt auch roguelike Elemente, die dich zurückziehen, bis zum Anfang deines Spiels auf die Todeszeit.
Die Spielweise war bis jetzt ein bisschen ambiguös, aber es sieht fantastisch aus.
Die Kommentare sehen aus, als ob Bioshock Infinite und DICE...
Das kann sogar sein, aber trotzdem...
Es ist ja nicht immer gesagt, dass die besseren Sachen sich durchsetzen.
...ein Baby hatten.
In klassischer Arkane-Fashion kann jede Mission in mehreren Weichen veröffentlicht werden.
Deathloop startet am 14. September.
Xbox und Bethesda donatieren 10.000 Dollar an die Montgomery County Humane Society
im Namen von River, dem Hund, der die Referenz für Fallout 4-Kompanion Dogmeat war.
River ist letztes Jahr weggegangen und war das Pett eines der Entwickler.
Das Team wollte einen professionell trainierten...
Ich finde das, ich finde das, by the way, super, dass die an irgendwelche...
Ich weiß nicht, an was sie donatiert haben, an irgendwelche Tierschutzgeschichten donatiert haben,
aber man muss halt mal ehrlich sagen, 10.000...
Das bezahlen die aus der Portokasse, oder nicht mal, das ist noch nicht mal die Portokasse.
10.000 ist so...
Das ist das, was die wahrscheinlich zufällig auf dem Gang finden im Management-Stock oben.
...Stockwerk.
...Active Dog for the role, but eventually settled on using River instead.
On top of replicating Rivers' likeness, the developers also used recordings of her barks and other sounds for Dogmeat.
The used GPU market is getting a massive influx of RTX 3060 and 3080s...
Ja, das stimmt.
...thanks to China banning...
...in Crypto-Mining.
Das stimmt, Playerbase, Primordial Nightmare, Playerbase ist echt wichtig bei Multiplayer-Spielen.
Das ist mit eines der Faktoren schlechthin, ob ein Spiel langfristig erfolgreich ist oder nicht.
...racing has been falling for a couple of months now for both Nvidia and AMD hardware.
It's likely China's Crypto-Mining ban is playing a massive...
Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich, jetzt ohne Scheiß, Travorek, du hast recht,
wahrscheinlich haben die mehr Geld dafür bezahlt, Influencern Geld zu geben,
dass die Nachricht verbreitet wird, dass sie 10.000 Euro donated haben,
als die 10.000 Euro, die sie donated haben.
Wahrscheinlich, dass das wäre so ein richtig typischer Stonks-Move.
Man donated 10.000 Euro und gibt dann 100.000 Euro aus, um zu verbreiten, dass man 10.000 Euro donated hat.
Das wäre ein typischer BWL-Stonks-Move, kann ich mir gut vorstellen.
Florian 290, danke für den Sub.
Roll in the downturn.
Chinese mining operations are unloading thousands of GPUs under MSRP onto local reseller sites.
These listings probably...
They aren't available outside of China, but they should still help knock down pricing for new GPUs and deflate the used market.
The medium developer Blooper Team denies that they're working on a new Silent Hill title
as part of their new partnership with the franchise's owner Konami.
Speculation has run wild that a new Silent Hill game is in development by either Blooper Team or Hideo Kojima.
Blooper Team says that they have two active internal projects.
Neither of them is based on themes or premises that have been circulating,
online in the last few days, meaning no Silent Hill stuff is in the works.
The medium is about as close to a new Silent Hill game as it gets, so if any studio were
going to make a new entry in the franchise, Blooper Team would be a good fit.
Before we...
Wofür steht eigentlich Stonks für Aktien?
Stock?
Stocks?
Before we get to this week's final story, I just want to say thanks for tuning in.
We'll be back on Monday with another episode of Today in Gaming.
Get subscribed and enable notifications.
We'll be back on Monday with another episode of Today in Gaming. Get subscribed and enable notifications.
So you don't miss it and also check the description for those origin PC links.
Yeah.
The Witcher 3 is getting a new DLC based on the Netflix adaptation of the novels.
What?
The show borrowed heavily from the games, characters and visuals, but is an original adaptation
of the book.
Moment.
We're going to get a Witcher 3 DLC in 10 years.
CD Projekt RED are releasing a next-gen Update for the Witcher 3 later this year and will
include extra items
Okay, okay, nee, nee, nee, es bekommt keinen eigenen Story-DLC, es bekommt ein paar extra Items.
Das heißt im Endeffekt, äh, keine Ahnung, äh, zwei Tage Entwicklungsaufwand oder sowas.
Null!
Wie?
Wie, wie billig?
Wie billig? Ich dachte, es gibt neue Story. Nein, nein, nein, nein, gibt's nicht.
Würden die den Add-on raushauen mit neuer Story, würde ich sofort kaufen, aber was, wen juckt mich, was juckt mich Items aus der Serie?
Ich mein, uninteressanter kann's ja kaum sein.
Und das beendet es für diese Woche in Gaming. Wie immer, Leute, danke für's Zuschauen und wir sehen uns nächste Woche.
Das war LevelCaf, sign off.
Das ist ja für das Geld, was sie zur Verfügung haben, jetzt erst einmal nicht so, also die haben ja das Geld von Cyberpunk trotzdem bekommen.
Scheiß drauf.
Scheiß drauf, ob ihr, ob ihr Aktienkurs runtergeht oder nicht.
Das betrifft sie doch erst mal gar nicht.
All in.
Ich warte schon auf die nächsten Reddit, ähm, wenn das, wenn das jetzt noch weiterfällt, dann kommt demnächst, äh, Wallstreetbets an und macht CD Projekt Red.
Kommt irgendwas.
So, was gucken wir uns jetzt als nächstes an?
EA Activision war gestern.
Dieser Konzernbeherrsch geht, das, das, das wird wahrscheinlich, wo ist so Tencent?
Was sonst?
Das müssen wir uns nicht angucken.
China, China.
Chinesen, ähm, Simon Desue, Exposed, auch noch.
Exposed.
Wisst ihr Leute, Simon Desue, ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, warum ich das Video aufgemacht habe, aber, da ist das nicht der, ist das nicht der, der Simplicissimus-Typ?
Oder einer von den beiden?
Oder bring ich das jetzt durcheinander?
Ist das nicht der gleiche Typ?
Ja.
Och doch, doch, doch.
Ähm, also Simon Desue ist halt auch so einer, wo ich, keine Ahnung.
Hab, warum die Leute überhaupt, also erstens verstehe ich nicht, warum die Leute das jemals gefeiert haben, ich fand das persönlich schon immer mega unlustig, aber okay, aber, dass man da, dass man dem Kerl vertraut, irgendwas, verstehe ich nicht, ja.
Also, also ich persönlich finde den Typ mega unsympathisch, das ist so, Simon Desue ist der Typ, der früher in der Klasse immer einen dummen Spruch machen musste, egal wie unpassend es war.
Weil es eben so sein Ruf war, äh, äh, lustig, funny zu sein, da musste zu allem einen dummen Spruch machen, so jemand ist das.
Quasi, selbst wenn jemand erzählt hat, seine Oma ist gestorben, muss der einen dummen Spruch machen, so schätze ich den Kerl ein.
Gut, keine Ahnung, ob's, ob's wirklich stimmt, aber zumindest ist, ist mir der Typ mega unsympathisch.
Guck mal, guck mal mal, ich will jetzt wissen, wie, wie der Ex post wird.
Doch, das ist der doch.
Alter, wenn ich dieses, dieses, dieses...
Wenn ich diese gestellten, wenn ich diese gestellten, ähm, Reicht, wenn ich diese gestellten Reichtumsbilder schon immer sehe, da kann ich auch mit Karl auf den Mount Everest, da brauch ich nicht Simon Desue.
Und Simon hat jetzt einen neuen, ekelhaften, mutmaßlichen Scam.
Den haben wir uns mal etwas genauer angeguckt und etwas dazu recherchiert.
Spoiler, seine Masche stammt aus den USA, hat zig Menschen in den Ruin getrieben, ist aufgebaut auf dem Standardbaukasten der dubiosen Online-Coaches...
Oh Gott, nein, nicht noch mehr.
Okay, okay, Coaching, Coaching, Online-Coaching, so in a, in a Nutshell.
Als erstes musst du den Leuten erzählen, Leute, ihr braucht das richtige Mindset, ihr müsst das Gewinnermindset haben, nur mit dem richtigen Gewinnermindset könnt ihr reich werden.
Ihr müsst richtig, wie, wie sagt er, ihr müsst hustlen, Leute, ihr müsst richtig ran, ihr müsst richtig reinklopfen, das Gewinnermindset, ihr dürft nicht anscheinend, das Gewinnermindset.
Und dann, und dann müsst ihr natürlich meine Produkte verkaufen.
So.
Ihr braucht das richtig krasse Gewinnermindset und müsst meine Produkte verkaufen.
Dann werdet ihr reich.
Das ist immer exakt die gleiche scheiß Masche.
Dass das da überhaupt noch, das ist ja noch nicht einmal was...
Warte mal, Alter, ich muss was trinken.
ETF.
Alter, na, wann bin ich jetzt Corona geimpft, ey?
Okay.
Alles gut, alles...
So.
Weiter im Text.
Also, es ist ja noch nicht mal...
Dass diese ganze, diese ganze Masche hier mit, ich mache euch reich, das ist garantiert sowas, werde ich mit euch, wenn ich das hier schon sehe, das ist ja gar nicht so, als ist diese Masche neu.
Diese Masche gibt es quasi schon ewig online und noch viel, viel länger offline.
Dass man den Leuten für viel Geld quasi irgendwelche, soll man sagen, irgendwelche Träume verkaufen will oder ihnen bei irgendwas angeblich hilft, sei es reich werden, sei es den Traumpartner,
finden, was auch immer und diese Masche gibt es ja schon, schon tausende Jahre im Endeffekt.
Ich sage das aus eigener Erfahrung.
Ich habe sowas noch nie gemacht, aber mein Vater hat sowas gemacht.
Mein Vater hatte eine Scam-Firma früher, die nicht zwar sowas gemacht hat, aber ähnliche Sachen gemacht hat, ja.
Also, ich habe mitbekommen, was da, was da so abläuft.
Das heißt, das ist nicht, das ist nicht neu.
Das hat er schon vor 40 Jahren gemacht, ohne Internet und alles.
Das, diese Masche ist nicht neu.
So, okay, gucken wir uns das jetzt mal an.
Also, wer sich jetzt fragt, was der, ich erzähle es jetzt mal ganz kurz, um ganz kurz zu erklären, was der gemacht hat.
Der hatte eine Partnervermittlung, hatte aber nie vor, Partner zu vermitteln.
Der hat quasi irgendwelchen älteren Damen, ich sage mal Omas, erzählt zum Beispiel bei uns,
bei mir findet ihr euren Traumpartner, der, der perfekt zu euch passt und hat mit denen einen monatlichen Vertrag ausgemacht.
Die haben krasse Kohle abgedrückt für die damalige Zeit, die Omas.
Und anstatt den Partner zu vermitteln, hat er sich drei, vier Herren in, in ein bisschen gehoberenem Altern,
die halt auch nett ausgesehen haben und gut reden konnten, hat er bezahlt, dass die für ihn zu den, zu den Omas gegangen sind
und denen quasi schöne Augen gemacht haben.
Und daraufhin haben natürlich die Omas immer schön weiter Monatsgebühren bezahlt,
weil ja so viele nette Herren bei ihnen Interesse haben und vorbeikommen.
Also dieses, diese Masche, diese Scammasche ist ur, uralt.
Tja, das ging dann übrigens auch irgendwann in die Hose, weil sie ihn erwischt haben, aber Scammers.
Online Coaches und Future Digital Millionaires und richtet sich ganz gezielt auf Menschen in unserer Gesellschaft, die den nicht haben.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nicht im Knast, nicht im Knast.
Wobei, okay, ich, Leute, ich, ich, ich bin ehrlich, er war nicht im Knast und nicht dafür.
Er war nur in Untersuchungshaft, aber nicht dafür.
Dafür, er war, sie haben ihn versucht, ja, sie haben ihn versucht zu verklagen dafür
und der Richter muss wohl eins zu eins gesagt haben, also gut, ich kenne das nur von dem, was er so erzählt hat.
Der Richter muss wohl wirklich gesagt haben zu, zu, zu, zu so einer, zu so einer, äh,
Zeugin, Frau, die damals da Kunde war, muss wohl wirklich gesagt haben,
Frau, ich sage jetzt mal Frau Meier, keine Ahnung, wie die hieß, Frau Meier, warum haben Sie denn sowas unterschrieben?
Also das muss wohl so ein offensichtlicher Scam-Vertrag gewesen sein,
der sich rechtlich, also nicht Scam, strafbar Scam, aber offensichtlich sehr einseitig
und der muss sich gefragt haben, Frau Meier, warum haben Sie sowas denn unterschrieben?
Die haben ihn ja gefragt, also der hat, der hat krass Leute gescampt, aber die haben ihn freigesprochen.
Das war rechtlich nichts zu...
Das war rechtlich nichts zu machen. Da wahrscheinlich auch nicht, ja?
Aber was ich halt sagen will, so Scam-Geschichten sind schon so alt wie die Menschheit.
Bevor es losgeht, ganz kurz zum Sponsor des heutigen Videos, das ist mal wieder NordVPN.
VPNs sind nützlich, wenn man...
Wo wir gerade bei Scam sind.
...virtuell den eigenen Standort ändern will.
So kann man ziemlich unterschiedliche Angebote.
In den USA gibt es ganz andere Filme, das hat zum Beispiel jemanden von euch interessiert.
NordVPN ist auch super schnell, ihr dürftet also auch...
Richtig schnell.
...sowohl für iOS.
Wenn euch NordVPN nicht gefällt, gibt NordVPN...
Ja, auf jetzt.
...erinnert euch an...
...Rabatt auf einen Zwei-Jahres-Plan.
Ihr alle erinnert euch an Simons Klassiker wie englische YouTube-Videos 1 zu 1 übersetzen.
Ehrlich gesagt, nein, daran erinnere ich mich nicht, weil ich das nie geguckt habe.
Weil ich den Kerl von Anfang an mega unsympathisch fand.
Es wird mir jedes Mal bis zum Rest meines Lebens eine Gänsehaut den Rücken runterjagen.
Hi, I'm Chris Brown.
Asshole.
Pfff, Hanna.
Oder bei einer Mini-Verfolgungsjagd dabei sein.
Oder auch einen Jet-Ski mieten.
Oder sich vor einem Eintages-Auto-Rental stellen und so tun, als würde man es besitzen.
Oder billige Scheiß-Zahnpflegen bewerben.
Oder in Dubai leben, weil man da ja so frei ist.
Ach, stimmt.
Das ist ja einer von den Dubai-Influencer...
Wie nennt man das?
Keine Ahnung.
Gruppe.
Was gibt's denn?
Es gibt die Madeira-Influencer und es gibt die Dubai-Influencer.
Gibt's noch was?
Hab ich noch was vergessen?
Haben wir noch ein paar?
Warum geht eigentlich keiner in die Schweiz?
Zu teuer.
Zu, zu, äh, auch zu viel Steuern.
LA-Influencer.
Ah, gibt's die auch noch?
Und jenen kleinen Scam durchziehen.
Man merkt schon, es wurde über die Jahre immer weniger lustig und einfach immer krimineller und hinterhältiger und ekelhafter.
Ja gut, er muss halt sehen, dass er aus seiner, ähm, schwindenden, keine Ahnung, Fanbase, die ihm da noch traut,
das maximale an Kohle rausholt, ne?
Hatte am Freitag ein Vorstellungsgespräch zum Fachinformatiker.
Interessiert es dich vielleicht, welche Fragen sie gestellt haben?
Ja? Ja?
Können wir uns, können wir uns gleich mal angucken?
Ich guck mir jetzt das Video an.
Ja, das können wir uns, eine gute Idee.
Simon, das hier vor einigen Wochen einen neuen augenscheinlichen Scam gestartet.
Glaubst du, dass es Menschen gibt, die online mehr Geld verdienen als 5000 Euro im Monat?
Fuck.
Du wärst...
Ja.
Ich kenn auch einen, der gerne noch mehr verdienen würde.
Das ist dumm, wenn du nein sagst.
Ich mach's ganz kurz.
Er verspricht, dass man über FBA, das ist Fulfillment by Amazon, richtig heftig reich...
Fulfillment by...
Äh, ähm...
Das ist Marketplace, oder?
Das ist ganz normales Amazon Marketplace, oder?
Sehe ich das jetzt falsch?
Du verkaufst deine Sachen über Amazon und, ähm...
Du machst halt, du machst halt, äh, Fulfillment, also sprich Versand und du machst halt die Abwicklung über Amazon.
Reich werden kann 5000 Euro die Woche, 10.000 Euro die Woche...
Also du schickst, du schickst deine Sachen quasi an Amazon, an irgendein, an irgendein Amazon-Logistikzentrum, lässt es da lagern und Amazon verschickt es dann, wenn es einer kauft.
...Geld verdienen.
Und was Fulfillment by Amazon eigentlich ist...
Damit kann man, damit kann man, damit kann man, wusste ich gar nicht, dass man damit angeblich krass Geld machen kann.
...das Amazon dir anbietet, okay, wenn du ein Produkt hast, schick es einfach in unsere Lagerhäuser, wir verkaufen das für dich auf unserer Plattform, also beziehungsweise wir schicken es halt raus, wir holen es zurück, wir machen Returns, Kundenservice und halt alles für eine Commission.
Ja, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Und da haben sich...
Du schickst das palettenweise an Amazon und die machen den Rest, so einfach ist es ja nicht, deren Scheiß muss ja jemand erstmal kaufen.
Du musst den Kram einkaufen und du musst, du musst dafür sorgen, dass die Leute den Kram verkaufen und dann musst du auch irgendwie Gewinn mitmachen.
Einige smarte Leute haben mal gedacht, oha, was wenn wir einfach super billige China-Produkte nehmen, so Handy-Cases oder so...
China-Chinesen-Kram, beste Idee.
...über Amazon...
High-Quality-Produkte kommen immer gut an.
...verkaufen, so, da ist auch was für Small-Businesses, etc., etc.
Und dafür bietet...
...Simon jetzt ein krasses Coaching an, weil er behauptet, dass er damit auch unfassbar...
Kaum um alles in der Welt braucht man dafür ein Coaching.
...viel Geld verdient, er ist einfach der FBA-Gott.
Dafür hat er eine super billige Clickfunnels-Page erstellt, deswegen sehen die übrigens alle immer gleich aus, weil es dafür so ein Service quasi gibt, clickfunnels.com.
Er hat bei seiner geilen Clickfunnels-Seite nicht mal den Infotext der Webseite geändert, da steht tatsächlich No-Cost-Training vor, in eckigen Klammern, Market, weil man da halt dann einfügen soll...
Ja gut, jetzt kannst du dich nicht erwarten, dass Simon...
...ein Webdesigner ist.
...No-Cost-Training macht, also der hat das Template nicht mal vernünftig angepasst, das ist so billig.
Man kann nicht sehen, wer die Domain registriert hat.
Und mit seinem geilen Amazon-Dropshipping verdient er bestimmt auch nicht genug, dass er da mal einen Webdesigner bezahlen kann.
Da hat er anonymisiert, schade.
Es gibt auf jeden Fall dieses Video, in dem er das alles...
Ich glaube, er müsste mal gecoacht werden, wie man eine Webseite macht.
Das ist super ekelhaft aufgebaut natürlich.
Letztes Jahr wurden auf Amazon über 386 Milliarden...
...Jahre den Dollar umgesetzt.
Ja und?
54% davon kommen von Verkäufern, wie ich es bin.
Und er sagt dann so richtig deepe, also wirklich tiefgehende, motivierende Sachen wie...
Und der Knackpunkt, einfach machen und tun.
Und auf Instagram hat er noch ein Video veröffentlicht...
Machen und tun?
Boah, huge coaching.
...Teilnehmer seines geilen Seminars, der in...
Das ist wie, das ist wie, das ist wie wenn in irgendeinem Online-Game, um zu gewinnen,
...die ich nicht mehr veröffentliche.
Also stell dir mal vor, ihr wolltet gut werden in einem Online-Spiel und lasst euch von einem Pro coachen...
...und der Coach sagt einfach zu euch, einfach nicht sterben.
Einfach nicht sterben und alle Gegner killen.
Das ist ungefähr genauso gehaltvoll wie dieses Coaching.
Hat irgendwie was von KLS-Vibes.
Ja klar, weil das alles der gleiche Crap ist.
...50 Dollar verdient hat.
Dieses Gefühl kann ich nicht in Worte fassen.
Und wie viel hast du seit dem Start verdient?
Ah, das sieht auch...
Sehen beide, die sehen beide wie super vertrauenswürdige Menschen aus, denen man jedes Wort glauben kann.
Vor allem, vor allem...
Ist das eine Goldkette, eine Silberkette, keine...
Wahrscheinlich auch irgendwie krasser Markenpulli, aber mit sowas kenne ich mich nicht aus.
Alles sehr vertrauenswürdige Leute.
Das ist kein Screenshot.
Moment, was?
4.856 US-Dollar.
Im Monat.
Gut, kommt auf die Menge an, die du verkaufst, ne?
Das ist kein Screenshot.
Oh, dann sieben Tage.
Ja, es kommt auf die Menge an, die du verkaufst.
Das ist, äh...
Ne?
Das geht schon.
Es ist halt die Frage, wie viel du verkaufst.
Und die Frage ist ja nicht nur, wie viel du verkaufst.
Die Frage ist ja auch, was bringt dir das im Endeffekt?
Ich meine, du musst den Kram bestellen.
Du musst den Kram eventuell irgendwo zwischenlagern, bevor es zu Amazon, was weiß ich, über welche Ecken du das schickst.
Du musst es verkaufen.
Du musst Steuern bezahlen.
Also die Frage ist, was bleibt am Ende übrig, ne?
Ich meine, 5.000 Dollar in sieben Tagen ist jetzt sicherlich nicht wenig.
Aber du musst es verkaufen.
Aber es kommt halt auf die Umstände an.
Es kann sein, dass davon kaum was übrig bleibt.
Aktualisieren.
Ja, das ist wohl kein Screenshot.
Aber leider sind Produktverkäufe der Umsatz der letzten sieben Tage.
Nicht der Profit.
In einfachen Worten, du kannst zwar 1.000 Produkte für 5 Euro verkaufen.
Das ist das, was ich im Prinzip sagen wollte.
Und so 5.000 Euro umsetzen.
Sie fragen, was am Ende rauskommt.
Wenn du aber nur 5 Cent Gewinn pro Stück machst, naja.
Aber es gibt noch mehr Anzeichen, dass das Ganze mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit...
...eine saftiger Scam ist.
Das Erste ist, dass die amerikanische Federal Trade Administration...
Mal ganz davon abgesehen, so eine Seite zum Refreshen mit irgendwelchen Zahlen drauf...
...kann dir jeder halbwegs kompetente Typ bauen, ja.
...diese Fälle verfolgt.
Nämlich so Get-Rich-Schemes von Wannabe-Amazon-Sellern.
Und wenn man sich das so durchliest, dann denkt man, dass sie direkt Simon verklagt haben eigentlich.
Get started selling on Amazon and make 5 to 10.000 dollars in the next 30 days.
Even if you've never sold anything online before.
Hört sich ähnlich an, ja.
Das klingt ja fast genau wie das Scheme von Simon.
Und das Lustige ist, dass diese Masche super alt ist.
Also diese Klage von der FTC ist von 2018 oder so.
Hier gibt es einen Artikel von The Atlantic Anfang 2019 über diesen Gold Rush auf Amazon.
FBA, mach dich reich.
Und dass da Leute eben übelst heftig über die Ohren gehauen wurden von diesen krassen Coaches.
Die Leute sind aber auch so blöd.
Die sind aber auch so blöd.
Warum macht man da mit?
Ich kann das nicht verstehen.
Okay, es ist ja, die richten sich ja absichtlich.
Doch, ich kann es verstehen.
Die richten sich ja absichtlich an Pepega-Leute.
Die man einfach übers Ohr hauen kann mit sowas.
2021 überlegt, dass es Zeit wird, dass er das mal in Deutschland probiert, I guess.
I don't know.
Einfach machen und tun.
Die Artikel haben wir euch alle verlinkt und so.
Das ist genauso wie diese Videos, die Karl S. immer macht mit seinen...
Was weiß ich, 5 Millionen Uhren.
Und dann hat er irgendwie so ein komisches Case mit Uhren drin,
die er danach wahrscheinlich wieder abgibt, da woraus er sich ausgeliehen hat.
2018 haben sich bei der FTC 50 Leute beschwert, dass sie da unglaublich viel Geld mit verloren haben,
weil ihnen versprochen wurde, boah, FBA, mach dich reich, hol dir irgendein Billo-China-Produkt.
Sell das, sell das, sell das.
Dann machst du deine 5.000 bis 10.000 Dollar die Woche.
Quatsch natürlich.
Und 25 von denen haben über 35.000 Dollar.
Gut, man sieht aber schon an einer Sache, dass die Leute auf allen Seiten echt doof sind.
Nämlich dadurch, dass so eine Seite wie wish.com überhaupt existiert.
Wish ist die Seite für China-Scammer, wo die Leute zu dumm sind, in China selbst zu bestellen.
Also sprich, die einzige Existenzberechtigung von Wish ist, weil Leute unfähig sind, in China zu bestellen.
Weil die Leute nicht in der Lage sind, auf AliExpress...
Genau, Wish heißt, ich kenne AliExpress nicht.
Ich bin zu dumm, bei AliExpress zu bestellen.
Das ist Wish.
Also Wish ist eigentlich die einzige Ex...
Also Wish existiert nur, weil Leute zu dumm sind, bei AliExpress was zu bestellen.
Und denen haben über 35.000 Dollar verloren.
Aber Simon Desue bietet auf jeden Fall ein Live-Training an.
Das ist alles live.
Also da ist man dann im Live-Chat mit ihm und kann sich live angucken, was er denn so zu sagen hat.
Hat im Chat mit anderen Leuten...
Nur leider hat TJ, ganz liebe Grüße gehen raus, falls du das siehst, schon demonstriert, dass das angebliche Live-Video natürlich nicht live ist.
Ich frage mich, ob der Chat wenigstens wirklich echte Leute sind oder Bots, dass es Aktivität faked, obwohl du der einzige Zuschauer bist.
Das deutet natürlich auch darauf hin, dass es einfach eine pre-recordete Masche ist.
Es wird keine Wiederholung geben.
Nein, auf gar keinen Fall.
Das Impressum von simonvideos.com slash live-training führt dann einfach zu getclients.com und getclients.com und getclients.com.
Es ist ein Learning Portal für Leute mit Digital Product Businesses, also für Coaches, Course Creators und so weiter und so fort.
Ah, vertrauenswürdig hoch 10.
Und dann stehen da so Sachen wie...
Oh, diese Bilder, diese Bilder triggern mich auch immer richtig.
Simon, und dann stehen da so Sachen wie...
Diese Bilder, das ist einfach immer...
Das ist, weil die Leute sind für sowas empfänglich, anders kann ich es mir nicht erklären.
Du bildest irgendwelche jungen Leute auf dem Schiff ab und irgendwie sollen die Leute dann denken, wenn man bei ihnen mal einen Kurs gemacht hat, dann geht es so steil aufwärts, dass man in einem halben Jahr in der Karibik auf einem Boot rumschippert und automatisch durch nichts zu Geld verdient.
Also...
Allein schon, wenn ich solche Bilder sehe, weißt du, es ist Scam.
Yikes.
Also, wenn Leute im Internet versprechen, dich reich zu machen und ihr Impressum verlinkt auf eine Seite, in der ein Typ dir verspricht, dich mit Kursen...
Wisst ihr, was mich auch immer so wahnsinnig triggert bei diesen ganzen Coach-Dingern?
Das sind alles mega junge Leute.
Ich sage nicht, dass es nicht junge Leute gibt, die erfolgen.
Ich sage nicht, dass es nicht junge Leute gibt, die erfolgreich sein können.
Aber das sind meistens so, keine Ahnung, 23, 24, 25-jährige Leute, die dir dann erzählen sollen, so baust du dein weltweites Business auf.
Wie will der das denn beurteilen können mit 25?
Selbst wenn es Leute gibt, und die gibt es, die mit 25 Jahren ein richtig krasses Business haben, lohnenswert darüber zu berichten, so nach dem Motto, hey, ich habe jetzt hier einen weltweiten...
Das macht nichts.
Das machst du dann, keine Ahnung, mit 40 oder so, dass du sagst, hey, guck mal, so ist es, das ist meine Erfahrung.
Aber es wirkt einfach total unglaubwürdig, wenn das alles irgendwie 25-jährige Speaker sind.
...verlinkt auf eine Seite, in der ein Typ dir verspricht, dich mit Kursen darüber, wie man Kurse macht...
Und die, die in dem Alter wirklich diese Kohle haben, haben was anderes zu tun, als auf solche Dinger zu gehen.
...reich zu machen, reich zu machen, dann weißt du...
Mal ganz davon abgesehen, eine Sache, die ich nie verstehen werde.
Die ich nie verstehen werde bei solchen Dingern ist, wenn ich wirklich den ultimativen Trick rausbekomme, da muss man sich ja mal überlegen.
Stellt euch mal vor, ihr habt wirklich den ultimativen Trick rausbekommen, diese eine Masche, mit der ihr ohne viel zu arbeiten, richtig krass reich werden könntet.
Würdet ihr das allen Ernstes für ein Apfel und ein Ei an jeden auf dieser Welt verkaufen, diese Information?
Im Leben nicht.
Niemals würde ich das verkaufen.
So dumm kannst du doch nicht sein.
Allein schon aus diesem Gesichtspunkt sind diese ganzen Coachings schon immer sehr fragwürdig.
Die tun immer so, als hätten sie so die Weisheit mit Löffeln gefressen und wissen das, was niemand außer ihnen auf der Welt weiß.
Und dann fragt man sich ja natürlich, wenn die doch so krass schlau sind, warum machen sie es nicht einfach, ohne jemanden zu erzählen?
Äh, okay. Das ist der kurze Rundown von Simons neuem mutmaßlichen Scam.
Und jetzt vielleicht mal so zum Ernst der Lage für eine Sekunde.
Also ich sag euch mal ernsthaft, bevor ich Amazon-Drop-Tripping mit Simon Desue mache, dann gehe ich lieber mit Karl auf den Mount Everest.
Und das würde ich auch nicht machen.
Und dann spricht er absichtlich den kleinen Mann an, den Arbeitnehmer, denjenigen, der sich vielleicht am einfachsten von solchen Versprechen locken lässt, weil der oder diejenige vielleicht am wenigsten hat.
Was hast du jetzt vorher gemacht in der Ausbildung?
Du hast ja schon erzählt, wie viel hast du da verdient, wenn ich fragen darf?
Wenn ich fragen darf? Nein!
Stellt euch mal vor, der wird gesagt, nein, darfst du nicht.
Ist ja überhaupt nicht geskriptet.
180 Euro netto.
Du hast jetzt das sozusagen in einer Woche schon mehr verdient.
Ach, das Fünffache.
Simon Desue ist einfach so eine Person, die sich um Reichtum und Luxus pflegt und versucht aufrechtzuerhalten mit gestellten Bildern, mit teuren Autos, mit prolligen Roomtouren,
mit seinem Influencer.
In Dubai, dazu wurde ja auch schon genug gesagt, zum Beispiel von Jan Böhmermann.
Und seine Maschen sind dann Dinge, mit denen er ganz gezielt Menschen mit wenig Geld anvisiert.
Viele werden jetzt denken, so was Ausbildung abbrechen, aber lohnt sich auf jeden Fall für Amazon, dank Simon natürlich.
Das heißt es nicht, dass ihr sofort eure Ausbildung abbrechen solltet.
Ich nehme die nicht jetzt sofort als Vorbild.
Aber ich glaube, bei dir war es echt so, dass du...
Oh, das tut ja weh.
Ich wünsche mir wirklich von ganzem Herzen den Simon Desue zurück.
Der Thumbnail.
Der Thumbnails klaut und umphotoshoppt und Chris-Brown-Apology-Reactions eins zu eins nachspielt.
Das ist zwar auch alles wahnsinnig peinlich, aber immerhin nicht das hier.
Entweder werde ich abgezogen oder nicht.
Aber ich habe vertraut.
Ich habe vertraut.
Das ist natürlich das krasseste Argument schlechthin.
Die Scammer sagen dir, du sollst den Scammern vertrauen.
Das wirkt aber vertrauenswürdig.
Ich entscheide dich jetzt für dein Leben.
Vielleicht habe ich auch schon bald mit dir so ein Interview wie mit Ümit.
Ohne Scheiß.
Ich würde Geld dafür bezahlen, dass ich nicht ein Interview mit Simon Desue hätte.
Wir nehmen nur die Leute an, wo wir wissen, die werden Vollgas geben.
Wo wir wissen, wir können denen zum Erfolg verhelfen.
Wenn wir der Meinung sind, das passt irgendwie nicht, dann sagen wir das auch.
Ey, sorry, passt nicht.
Und dann weiter geht's.
Aber wenn du dabei bist...
Ach, sorry, du bezahlst zu wenig Geld raus.
Dann musst du auch Vollgas geben.
Ich hoffe, das Video hat euch gefallen.
Kleiner Rant.
Musste mal sein.
Einen richtig nice und entspannten Tag oder Abend.
Schaut nach links und rechts, wenn ihr über die Straße geht.
Feiert gut.
Und Case closed.
Ich hoffe, dass einfach wirklich auch Leute, die Simon Desue schon seit, keine Ahnung, 2013 oder...
Oder der ist ja noch länger als ich auf YouTube.
Der ist seit 2009 oder irgendwie so.
Seit 2009 auf YouTube folgen und irgendwie mit ihm da lustige, gute Sachen verbinden.
Was auch immer, ja.
Und einfach ein bisschen leichtgläubig sind und denken, so diese Masche...
Was ja auch immer gerne erzählt wird, ist so nach dem Motto, Leute, ich habe schon alles erreicht.
Aber jetzt ist es Zeit, dass ich ja meine Community mal was zurückgebe.
Jetzt zeige ich euch, wie ich es gemacht habe.
So, das ist ja oftmals die Masche auch.
Hat auch gerade jemand im Chat geschrieben.
Die dann wirklich glauben, so nach dem Motto, so ein guter Mensch, der gibt den Leuten jetzt was zurück.
Und erzählt ihnen, wie es wirklich geht.
Und die dann da drauf reinfallen.
Das ist halt das...
Das Bittere ist halt, dass es tatsächlich die letzten verbliebenen, richtigen Fans trifft, die er hat.
Und die verarscht er dann auch noch.
Ist halt für den Arsch, ne?
Aber gut, so sind die Leute halt.
Also solche Leute.
Da machst du nix.
Gibt es ein Scam-FPS-Business-Programm mit Herr Endpunkt?
Herr Endpunkt meldet sich in letzter Zeit leider im Discord nicht mehr.
Ich wollte mit ihm ja ein Video aufnehmen.
Er hat sich ja...
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich euch das erzählt habe.
Er hat sich ja gemeldet im Discord.
Ich habe jetzt auch verraten, dass er Niklas heißt.
Das hat er mir erlaubt.
Und ich wollte mit ihm eigentlich ein Video aufnehmen.
Aber irgendwie ist er in letzter Zeit nicht mehr am Start.
Aber gut, dann...
Dann machen wir das, wenn er wieder da ist.
So.
Letzte Chance.
Letzte Chance, YouTube uns was Gutes vorzuschlagen.
Sonst gucken wir mal was anderes.
Top Concerns Battlefield 2042.
Tja, das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an.
Redis in 100 Sekunden.
Nee.
Redis kann man in 5 Sekunden eigentlich beschreiben.
Es ist RAM mit einer Query Language.
Oder nicht mal eine Query Language.
Ähm.
Es ist dein RAM, auf den man strukturierter zugreifen kann.
Fertig.
RAM, auf den man organisierter zugreifen kann.
Oh.
Ja gut, schwierig zu beschreiben jetzt.
Zumindest RAM.
RAM.
In Memory.
Ich sag mal so, Redis kannst du glaube ich auch auf Persistent machen, auf SSD.
Aber dass es schnell ist, dass es sich lohnt, muss das in RAM.
Redis RAM as a Service.
Genau.
RAM as a Service ist Redis.
So kann man das gut beschreiben.
So, was haben wir sonst noch hier?
10 Gigabit auf einem Raspberry Pi.
Na gut, mit PCI Express ist das geil.
Ach.
Guter Switch, Leute.
Guter Switch.
Ach, Bewerbungsfragen.
Stimmt.
Bewerbungsfragen.
Ja, ihr habt recht.
Also, zeigt mal her.
Wo hat es denn...
Irgendwas...
Ähm.
Kass.
Irgendwas Kass, oder?
Nee.
Kass.
Irgendwas mit Underscore im Namen.
Äh.
Wie hieß das?
Wie hieß er denn?
Bewerbung.
Kuss, nicht Kass.
Kuss.
Also.
Ah, ja.
Äh.
Hatte Vorstellungsgespräch.
Als Fall interessiert dich vielleicht, welche Fragen sie gestellt haben.
Jo.
Okay, also.
Sie haben gefragt, wofür ein Router...
Wofür ist ein Router zuständig?
Was macht DNS?
Was ist ein Gateway?
Was...
Ob...
Ihh.
Ich hoffe, die haben dich nichts berechnen lassen.
Musstest du was...
Nee, oder?
Das wäre mir auch zu fies, Leute, was berechnen zu lassen.
Und was...
Kann man damit alles einstellen?
Und als letztes, welche Games ich zocke?
Der eine hatte mich durch...
Haha.
Ja.
Exzellent.
Gut.
Und was hast du ihnen geantwortet?
Wofür ist ein Router zuständig?
Ich meine...
Noobs würden antworten, um zu routen.
Das ist aber nicht das, womit du punkten kannst bei...
Bei Vorstellungsgesprächen.
Oder um zu...
Um zu...
Um zu routen.
Für Routing ist der Router zuständig.
Der Router.
Ja.
Die einfachste Antwort ist natürlich...
Ein Router ist dafür da, um zwei unabhängige Netze miteinander zu verbinden.
Dass zwei...
Dass zwei unabhängige Netze miteinander reden können.
Von einem Netz ins andere Netz zu routen.
Zu welcher Stelle war...
Stimmt, als was hast du dich beworben?
Es wäre vielleicht interessant zu wissen.
Fachinformatiker?
Und dann welcher?
Moment, nur dass ich das richtig jetzt verstehe.
Nur dass ich das jetzt richtig verstehe.
Du möchtest, dass ich auf dein Video reacte.
Nee.
Heute nicht.
Ich habe festgestellt, es wäre ein Router ohne Modems hergestellt.
Aber irgendwie fast keine Modems ohne Router mehr.
Ähm.
Ja.
Das stimmt.
Allerdings nur im Heimbereich.
Im Businessbereich gibt es das alles sehr wohl.
Ja, okay.
Die Frage, was macht DNS, ist eigentlich auch Standard.
Ich glaube, wenn man da sagt Namensauflösung, Domain zu IP.
Und sicher.
Was ist ein Gateway?
Naja, der Gateway ist in der Regel das Interface vom Router, was man an seinem Endgerät einstellt,
damit man in ein anderes Netz kommt, über den Router.
Das hängt ja stark damit zusammen.
Subnet-Maske kommt da noch.
Und was man damit alles einstellen und letzt...
Ja, das finde ich aber cool, dass sie dich fragen, welche Spiele du spielst.
Da sieht man, dass mittlerweile dort auch Leute sitzen, die für die Spiele nicht das Teufelszeug ist.
Ja, finde ich gut.
Du hast das Rezept.
Einfach erben, das Geld.
Ja, das kann man machen.
Easy.
Doch, doch.
Das ist, glaube ich, der gleiche Typ.
Ja.
Es ist nicht mal ganz so kaputt, die Standard-Apps.
Aber wirklich, wirklich überzeugt hat es mich immer noch nicht.
Pato, Heli, Dankeschön für die 11-Monats-Subscription.
Das ist ja eins vor...
Wundert mich, dass noch niemand einen Coin gemacht hat, der auf RAM gemeint wird.
Doch, doch, gibt es schon.
So gut wie jedes Mining braucht RAM.
Aha.
Als was hast du dich beworben?
Da kam kein Netzwerk.
Das hängt immer ganz entscheidend davon ab, wer da sitzt in so einem Vorstellungsgespräch.
Also bei uns ist es leider, leider, muss ich sagen, bei uns ist es leider so,
dass im Vorstellungsgespräch Fachinformatik und Systemintegration,
da sitzt der Ausbildungsleiter für alle Azubis,
also sprich, der hat von Technik und Tut und Blasen keine Ahnung,
und irgendwie einen Personalmensch.
Das heißt, niemand, der wirklich...
Wer wirklich Ahnung von Technik hat, sitzt bei uns in einem fiesen Vorstellungs...
Vorstellungs...
Bewerbungsgespräch.
Das heißt, kannst du komplett knicken.
Das heißt, selbst mit Technikfragen kommst du da nicht weiter.
Du kommst bei uns...
Du wirst bei uns, also lustigerweise, echt so,
du wirst bei uns als fiesi eher eingestellt,
wenn du einen ordentlichen Anzug anhast,
als wenn du technische Ahnung hast.
Tja.
Sind sie aber selber dran schuld.
Sie sind selber dran schuld, wenn sie nicht gute Leute kriegen.
Mit solchen Sachen.
Ich...
Was?
Ich wurde auf eurer...
Ich wurde auf einer Bewerbung gefragt, ob ich auch in Games raide.
Ja, finde ich, ist eine gute Frage.
Das finde ich, ist eine gute Frage.
Ohne Scheiß.
Wenn mir jemand erzählt, der ist MMO Progression Raider,
weiß ich, der kann auf jeden Fall gut mit anderen Leuten an was arbeiten,
um ein gemeinsames Ziel zu erreichen.
Progression...
Ich hab's doch schon in meinem Homeoffice-Video gesagt.
MMO Progression Raider ist die eigentliche Homeoffice Master Race.
Wenn du dir sicher sein kannst, dass einer gut im Homeoffice arbeiten kann
und auch gut zusammenarbeiten kann,
dann sind das MMO Progression Raider.
Die wissen, wie man online kommuniziert.
Die wissen, wie man mit anderen online zusammenarbeitet,
sodass was Gescheites rauskommt.
Wie stehst du zu Winfo...
Was?
W-Info...
Ach, Wirtschaftsinformatik, Leute.
Äh...
Mir ist eigentlich egal, was jemand studiert hat, gemacht hat oder sonst wie.
Wenn er seine Aufgabe ordentlich erfüllt, die er hat,
habe ich damit keine Schmerzen.
Natürlich, du hast immer Leute, die keinen Plan haben.
Wir hatten auch mal einen, der hat erzählt, er hat fortgeschrittene VMWare-Erfahrung.
Und wenn man ihn gefragt hat, hat er gesagt, er hat mal eine Ubuntu-VM installiert.
Tja.
Also, das ist fragwürdig teilweise, was da erzählt wird.
Aber das beste Bewerbungsgespräch aller Zeiten,
das muss ich euch jetzt nochmal kurz einwerfen.
Also, das beste Bewerbungsgespräch aller Zeiten, was ich bei uns mitbekommen habe, war folgendes.
Da hat sich jemand bei uns beworben.
Und der hatte einen Abschluss in Mathe.
Der hat Mathe studiert.
Mit Abschlussarbeit und allem.
Und es kamen so ein paar Technikfragen.
Und irgendwann ging es dann um seine Abschlussarbeit.
So nach dem Motto, ja, über was hat dann einer gefragt von den Leuten, die da beigesessen haben.
Über was war dann ihre Abschlussarbeit?
Und dann hat er dann gesagt, ja, über was war denn ihre Abschlussarbeit?
Und dann hat er dann gesagt, so, ich denke mir jetzt mal irgendwas aus.
Ja, ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt nicht mehr genau.
Irgendwie sowas, was ich, das dritte Theorem von XY oder sowas.
Oder, oder, was weiß ich, irgendwas mathematisches hat er gesagt.
So.
Und normalerweise, normalerweise wäre jetzt das Bewerbungsgespräch an dieser Stelle durch gewesen.
Weil alle, die da gesessen hätten, hätten halt gesagt, okay, drittes Theorem von XY.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wovon der Typ spricht.
Nice, alles gut.
Der Typ hatte nur Pech.
Der Typ hatte bei uns richtig, richtig großes Pech.
Weil in diesem Bewerbungsgespräch saß einer, der einzig im Umkreis von, keine Ahnung,
na gut, in Frankfurt ist eine Uni, aber ich sage jetzt einfach mal,
einer der Handvoll Leute im Umkreis von 500 Kilometern, der wusste, was das ist.
Wir haben nämlich bei uns einen auf der Arbeit, der, ähm, also der, der, der, das ist,
das ist ein riesen, riesen Mathe-Fan und der arbeitet quasi nur, um Geld zu verdienen bei uns
und löst, ist in irgendeiner Mathe, Mathe, Mathe, ich habe keine Ahnung, wie das heißt,
in irgendeiner Mathe-Vereinigung und im Prinzip, der beschäftigt sich in seiner kompletten Freizeit
mit dem Lösen, also mit dem, mit dem, mit dem Beschäftigen von ungelösten mathematischen Problemen.
Also der, der geht da wirklich nur arbeiten, um ein bisschen Geld zu verdienen und die restliche Zeit hat der Typ,
ist er am Lösen mathematischer Probleme.
Also das ist, wie gesagt, einer von Handvoll Leuten im Umkreis von, keine Ahnung, 500 Kilometern,
der, der, der, der wirkt, der Wissen hätte wissen können, von was der spricht.
So, und, und dann kam halt, wie es kommen muss, dann sagt er, ah, das ist aber interessant,
wie war denn nochmal das dritte, die dritte Theorie, ich kenne, die zweite kenne ich,
aber was war denn nochmal die dritte?
Und da muss den Typ so übelst aus der Fassung gebracht haben, dass er gemeint hat, so irgendwie,
ah, äh, da kann ich jetzt nicht,
drüber reden, mein Abschluss, mein Abschlussprojekt ist geheim, da darf ich nichts zu sagen,
da muss ich übelst krass rausgeredet haben.
Der hat halt gedacht, er sagt irgendwas super mathematisches, wo er eh keine Ahnung von hat
und dann ist die Sache durch.
Ob der Typ überhaupt ein abgeschlossenes Studium hat, weiß ich bis heute nicht.
Studium auf Wish bestellt, ja, das ist halt echt,
das ist, vergangt, der hat wirklich, aber der hat auch echt Pech gehabt,
muss man mal sagen.
sagen. Wer kann denn damit rechnen, dass
der Einzige,
einer der Handvoll Leute in Deutschland, die dazu
was sagen können, ausgerechnet bei ihm im Bewerbungsgespräch
mitsitzt, ey.
Bei mir wollten sie beim Gespräch nur
wissen, was ich gemacht habe. Ja, da.
Die Story, also ich hab, ich hab sehr
viel, Leute, wie lang stream ich jetzt schon seit
drei Jahren? Ich hab die ein oder andere
Story ja schon öfters mal erzählt, ja.
Mega Pech,
ja. Das ist, eigentlich
ist das ein richtig gutes,
richtig guter Videotitel.
Studium
auf Wish bestellt.
Ja, das Thema hatten wir heute schon.
Aber man weiß ja nicht so genau, woran es gelegen hat,
dass die, dass die ganze Infrastruktur
down ist.
Oder ist da mittlerweile mehr rausgekommen?
Ey, solche
Fragen gehen mir auch immer auf den Keks.
Das sind so, so genannte
Brainteaser-Fragen. Und das
schwappt langsam aus den USA
zu unseren Bewerbungsgesprächen rüber.
Nur mit dem Unterschied,
was, was ich auch immer nicht
verstehe, ja. Also,
wenn, wenn Google
oder Facebook, Microsoft, Apple,
wer auch immer, so komischen Fragen
stellen und mit den Leuten an der Tafel
äh, Binary Trees inverten
und sowas in der Richtung,
dann ist das Google, Microsoft, also
das sind quasi Firmen mit,
die, die die größten, die Big Brains
der Welt suchen für sich. Okay.
Aber nur, weil das Microsoft, Apple
und Google und Facebook und Netflix
und, und sowas macht, das,
muss das nicht die 0815
Software-Klitsche in Frankfurt um die Ecke
machen.
Aber übrigens, dank der Hilfe zu meiner Bewerbung
auf deinem Discord mein Ausbildungspass.
Excellent, excellent. Leute, Ausrufezeichen
Discord, wenn ihr Big Brain Content braucht.
Und Ausrufezeichen Hetzner,
wenn ihr euren 20 Euro Hetzner-Startgutschein
claimen wollt. Hast du schon mal
das Heizungs-Nein noch nie?
Was hältst du von .NET 6?
Eine gute, gute Entwicklung.
Ja, und, und
diese, diese Fragen mit dem, wie viel Smarties
passen in einen Smartphone?
Das sind genau
solche Fragen, die, die,
die, diese Art der Fragen, die jetzt immer
mehr rüberschwappt aus den USA.
Und da geht's im Prinzip darum,
nicht, nicht, dass du die wirklich
beantworten kannst, sondern, dass man
quasi erklärt, wie man, wie man da
rangehen würde vom Ansatz her.
Aber ich find solche Fragen
trotzdem bescheuert.
Also ich find, richtig, richtig
hängengeblieben. Aber gut, man, man, man,
wir können ja fragen, was wir wollen.
Bei solchen Fragen soll man einfach nur laufen.
Genau, genau.
Bei uns sind bei Azubi-Bewerbern
kaum Fragen über fachliche Skills.
Weil, da gibt's, ja. Ja, ist
bei uns auch so. Wie gesagt, bei uns sitzen ja auch keine Technikleute
dabei. Bei uns sitzt der Oberausbildungsleiter
dabei, der keine Ahnung von Technik hat.
Und irgendwelche Personalleute kann man voll vergessen.
Mein Ansatz
wäre googeln. Ernsthaft, das würde ich auch antworten.
So, ja,
ab und zu bin ich auf Twitch. Aber ich bin,
ich bin ja nicht, nein, ich bin, ich bin wupplos.
Siehst du doch hier. Mensch.
Stimmt doch gar nicht. Fake News, Alter.
Fake News.
Also mein Vorstellungsgespräch
für die Ausbildung,
das könnte ich eigentlich mal, das könnte ich eigentlich mal
ein Video dazu machen.
Also mein Vorstellungsgespräch
für die Ausbildung war total easy.
Wir haben erst einen Test gemacht,
wo sie schon angekündigt haben, der Test ist
ähm, gemein.
Weil es der Test ist, den sie normalerweise auch
Leuten geben, die sie so einstellen.
So, und ich konnte davon ein paar Sachen beantworten.
Da war zum Beispiel auch die Frage drinne,
wie geht man aus Wim raus?
How to exit Wim?
Und sowas war da als Frage drin.
Irgendwelche IP-Tables, Tabellen
und sonst wie was. Also ich konnte zu einigen
Sachen tatsächlich was sagen, aber vieles
ja, keine Ahnung, war halt voll
voll verkackt, ja. Wusste ich damals nicht.
Zumindest in dem Gespräch
danach
war echt nicht, war echt nicht viel.
Ja.
Ich weiß noch, dass ich damals,
als ich das Bewerbungsgespräch, also die haben dann
gesagt, okay, wer möchte anfangen? Ja, okay, gehe ich ja immer
als erster rein. Und,
die haben mich dann, noch
bevor die was sagen konnten,
hab ich halt so vor mich hin
gemurmelt, dass manche Fragen
echt fies waren in diesem Vorstellungs-,
in diesem Test.
Und da haben sie halt gefragt, ja, warum?
Da meinte ich halt so, ja, gerade bei den Cisco-Sachen,
da wusste ich teilweise, aber bin nicht mehr drauf gekommen,
bla bla bla. Da hatte man gleich so ein Gesprächsthema.
Ansonsten bin ich da raus,
mir haben nicht wirklich viel,
ja, großartig geredet,
keine Ahnung, zehn Minuten.
Und, einen Tag später haben die mich
angerufen, haben gesagt, ja, ähm, wann können
sie unterschreiben? Okay,
alles klar. Muss jetzt mal wieder zurück
auf YouTube, klar. Aber die Fragen,
die letzten Sachen guck ich mir hier noch an.
Aha.
Oh, richtig Big Brain.
Ja, ich, das ist
übrigens auch der Grund, warum ich's immer
ein bisschen schwierig finde, die Leute
quasi live,
wie soll ich sagen, live
komplexere Sachen auszufragen, weil es ist einfach
so, viele Leute, auch,
auch Leute, die wirklich, wirklich
gut sind und Big Brain haben,
können unter Druck
nicht kreativ denken.
Das ist aber auch normal. By the way,
deswegen, das ist, das ist eines der Gründe,
warum ich diese, diese, diese Taktik
mit Vorstellungsgesprächen, komplexe Sachen
zu fragen und implementiert zu haben,
nicht, nicht gut finde. Weil,
Programmieren und,
und über Probleme nachdenken ist,
da muss ich jetzt, da muss ich jetzt ein bisschen ausholen.
Das ist ein kreativer Prozess. Also,
wenn du jetzt ein Problem lösen willst, keine Ahnung,
du sagst, ich möchte was programmieren,
was, äh, mein Bildschirm
immer ab 17 Uhr
dimmt oder sowas. Irgendwie, eine
einfache, sagen wir mal, eine einfache Aufgabe, ja,
da musst du, musst du kreativ sein, da musst du überlegen,
okay, wie mach ich das mit der Uhrzeit, wie
handel ich, keine Ahnung, mal ein Schaltjahr,
wie mach ich hier, wie mach ich jenes?
Das heißt, das ist, allein schon das
Überlegen ist ein kreativer Prozess
und das Programmieren und Implementieren und wie mach
ich das auch ein kreativer Prozess. So, und es
gibt zwei Sachen, die funktionieren
einfach nicht zusammen.
Das ist Stress,
Gefahr, Angst,
plus Kreativität. Das geht
nicht zusammen. Und wenn Leute
unter, unter Druck sind, schon ein bisschen
Panik haben, äh, oder angespannt
sind bei einem Vorstellungsgespräch,
dann kannst du von ihnen
keine kreativen Leistungen großartig
erwarten. Das, das geht einfach nicht
zusammen. Deswegen verstehe ich
nicht, wie man sich daraus was ableiten will.
Das hab ich noch nie verstanden und leuchtet mir
bis heute nicht ein. Das eine
passt mit dem anderen nicht zusammen.
Deswegen finde ich solche, solche Sachen bescheuert.
Ich, ich finde es viel sinnvoller, zu sagen,
hey, schick mal dein Github-Profil
mit, ich guck mir das, ich guck mir das an.
Da siehst du nämlich, was der Typ
macht, wenn er, wenn er seine Ruhe hat
und kreativ denken kann. Aber unter
Druck, kreativ, also Druck und kreativ
denken, da sind so, die beißen sich einfach.
Das ist ungefähr so, wie wenn
du einem Künstler sagst,
sag einem Maler, ja,
wenn du dem eine Pistole an den Kopf hältst
und sag, äh, sagst,
jetzt mal mal dein nächstes Meisterwerk.
Da kommt sicherlich nichts ordentliches
bei rum. Also, das kann nicht,
das kann nicht funktionieren.
Ey, wie viel Mathe haben die abgefragt?
So gut wie gar nichts.
Deine Worte, Worte munter, das ist doch schön.
Du, ich mach immer noch
YouTube-Videos, falls du das noch nicht mitgekriegt hast, aber
halt wenig, wenig zu Battlefield und Call of Duty
spiel ich ja gar nicht mehr.
Also, okay, weiter.
Gibt es momentan überhaupt eine Möglichkeit,
ein Bewerbungsgespräch nicht zu, nicht zu
bestimmt, bestimmt.
Solange es kein,
solange es kein, äh,
Nassi-Schneiderman-Struktogramm sein soll.
Äh, ja.
Ich muss euch sagen, das ist eines der Sachen, wo ich mich
echt komplett verschätzt habe.
Ich, ich sag ja, man muss ja auch zugeben können,
wenn man falsch liegt, Rainbow Six
hab ich komplett falsch eingeschätzt. Ich dachte, Rainbow Six
ist ein Game, das kommt raus, ich hab ja die Beta gespielt,
das kommt raus und nach
einem halben Jahr interessiert sich keine Sau mehr dafür.
Da lag ich komplett falsch.
Aber komplett.
Aber nicht bei einem Azubi.
Oder bei einem Programmierer.
Du schickst ja, du schickst ja,
du schickst ja eigentlich keinen Programmierer zu deinem
Kunde, dass der ihm dann, äh,
einen Flowchart malt oder einen
Implementierungsvorschlag live an der Tafel
erarbeitet. Das wär ja...
Und wenn, dann soll das irgendjemand anderes machen.
Ich würd das nicht machen.
So sollte, so sollte es meiner Meinung auch,
meiner Meinung nach auch zum größten Teil sein.
Man sollte hauptsächlich gucken,
dass es einstellungsmäßig
und, äh, menschlich miteinander passt,
dass man gut miteinander arbeiten kann und das ist eigentlich das Wichtigste.
Gerade
in der heutigen Zeit ist,
ist es doch eigentlich viel wichtiger,
dass man mit den Leuten, ähm,
wie soll ich sagen,
dass man mit den Leuten gut
im Team zusammenarbeiten kann, als dass sie
jetzt alles schon wissen, weil
du kannst gar nicht, also
es ist saumäßig schwierig für das
Spezifische, was du jetzt
machst, jemanden zu finden, der da
wirklich Ahnung von hat. Das ist heute
so viele Faktoren, die da zusammenkommen,
ähm, und
unterschiedliche Varianten. Wichtig ist eigentlich,
dass du jemanden hast, der Ahnung hat
und sich schnell einarbeiten kann und, und
der teammäßig zu deinen restlichen
Leuten dabei passt. Das ist meiner Meinung nach
das Wichtigste. Der muss soweit
Ahnung haben, dass er sich schnell einarbeiten kann
und soweit Ahnung haben, dass er weiß, nach was er suchen
muss. Dass der jetzt, dass du
jetzt den einen in Deutschland findest, der
exakt
dein eines Problem,
was du hast, lösen kannst, ist doch
unrealistisch. Äh, nicht wirklich.
Keine Ahnung.
Entwickler, Bachelorabschluss, kann ich nichts zu
sagen. Okay, gucken wir mal
weiter. Also, was
haben wir hier am Start noch?
10 Gigabit. Dieser, dieser Switch ist übrigens
richtig poggers. Den habe ich auch
hier. Das ist ein Mikrotik, ich glaube ein
C, C, CSS
oder CRS, äh, 305
ist das, glaube ich. Der ist wirklich poggers.
Was hat das bitte schon mit CCNA zu tun?
Ups.
Ich will eigentlich nur nochmal den Switch
sehen, ob das der richtige ist, den ich denke.
Ja, heißt
Das, das ist der, ich glaube das ist der,
das ist der CRS 305.
CRS 305, 305
Mikrotik.
Ja, ist der doch, sag ich doch hier.
Poggers. Super, ein super
Switch, Schrägstrich,
mit bisschen Routing Funktion,
nicht so wahnsinnig viel, aber bisschen kannst du mit
machen. Ähm, also
Bandbreiten mäßig, du routest damit jetzt
keine zwei Abteilungen über verschiedene
Stoffe, aber ansonsten ist das schon
in Ordnung. Der ist wirklich
gut, der ist nicht teuer, der kostet
glaube ich nur irgendwie
hier 100, 100,
112 Euro, oder 115 mit
Versand, 115 Euro.
Du bekommst einen Gigabit-Port und vier
10 Gigabit-Ports, äh, Glasfaser.
Eigentlich richtig gut. Home Network.
By the way, der Rest interessiert mich von dem Video, ehrlich gesagt
jetzt nicht, nicht so viel.
Haben wir, haben wir vielleicht noch,
Benchmarks?
Ja, genau.
Das ist nicht mal ein Bruchteil, nicht mal ein Bruchteil
von 10ern. Das liegt aber daran, dass
die PCI Express Bandbreite schlicht und ergreifend
zu, zu gering ist.
Man kann, by the way, man braucht überhaupt keine
10 Gigabit-Karte, man kann sich einfach auch ne 2,
genau, man kann, man kann 2,5
oder ne 5 Gigabit-Karte nehmen.
Das, äh, ist dann so effizient
von der Infrastruktur, je nachdem was man hat,
auch billiger. Aber es hat
eh kaum einen 2,5G oder
5G-Router bei sich daheim oder Switch.
Da ist es tatsächlich 10G einfacher
zu bekommen. Der, der große
Vorteil, warum sich das über kurz oder lang doch
durchsetzen wird, ist, weil du die Kabel
verwenden kannst, die schon da sind.
Für 10 Gigabit brauchst du meistens neue
Kabel, oder wenn du Glück hast, ist es gut.
Wenn es kurz genug ist, kannst du 10G auch über die alten
Kupferkabel machen, aber
eher nicht, oder du brauchst Glasfaserkabel.
2,5 und 5G
kannst du halt über die ganzen alten nur nach 15
Kupferkabel machen und das
ist halt für den Heimgebrauch
einfacher. RTX 4090,
das wird doch im Leben nicht stimmen.
So, also, was gucken wir
uns denn jetzt an?
Ah, Lockpicking-Lawyer,
das muss aus Prinzip immer sein.
Ne, K-Locks interessieren mich nicht.
Okay, Safe, Safe öffnen.
Cozy.
Cozy Safe.
Also das Video ist nur 1,30 lang,
das heißt, wir wissen jetzt schon,
wird das öfter
öffnen sein.
Jepp-Lock.
Hehehe.
Okay.
Easy, easy.
Hahaha.
Das ist so schlecht.
Alter.
Geil.
Lull.
So, was wollen wir uns jetzt, was gucken
wir uns denn jetzt noch an?
Irgendjemand hat gerade ein Video geschickt.
Was ist das?
Ah, das hatten wir schon mal
oft.
Ja, ja.
So, was gucken wir uns
jetzt noch an?
Irgendjemand hat gerade ein Video geschickt.
Was ist das?
Ah, das hatten wir schon mal oft.
Protect Linux-Servers from Hackers.
Oh.
Richtig, Hacker-Mans.
Das gucken wir uns mal an, aber nicht jetzt.
Protect from Chat.
Ist ja auch das Wichtigste.
Local Host.
Nein, du bist nicht immun gegen mich.
I wish I could play Battlefield 4 like this.
Battlefield angucken.
Komm, wir gucken uns eine Runde Battlefield an.
Hä? Moment, was ist das?
Zack, Zack.
Moment, was?
What the hell?
Was seh ich da?
Warum hat er einen Tunnel bei sich unter der Hütte?
Was?
Alter.
Das ist MonkaTos Musik wahrscheinlich.
Warum hat er einen Tunnel bei sich unter der Garage oder was das ist?
None funds their account.
Was?
Warum?
Ich mein, nice, aber...
Die viel wichtige Frage ist, warum hast du keinen Tunnel?
Ja, das stimmt, das könnte man auch so fragen.
Okay, er buddelt echt ernsthaft einen Tunnel bei sich unter der Hütte.
Ja, warum nicht? Kann man machen.
Kann man machen.
Okay, ja.
In Deutschland kann man das nicht machen, echt nicht?
Na gut, in Deutschland darfst du...
das nicht machen. Du darfst doch in Deutschland nicht einfach
einen Baum fällen bei dir auf dem Grundstück.
Deswegen darfst du bestimmt auch keinen Tunnel
buddeln bei dir auf dem Grundstück.
Illegale Unterkellerung.
Ernsthaft, sowas gibt es?
Bei uns in Deutschland ist das schon echt geil.
Du kannst auf deinem
eigenen Grundstück noch nicht mal machen, was du willst.
Der Wahnsinn.
Nach China oder Ami auswandern? Nee.
Wir könnten es bei uns einfach mal unseren Scheiß zusammenkriegen
und den Leuten mal ein bisschen mehr Freiheit lassen,
sowas zu machen auf ihrem eigenen Grundstück.
So, also komm, wir gucken uns mal eine Battlefield an.
Ich wusste, wir könnten uns mal eine Battlefield angucken.
Easy. Bam.
Bam. Bisschen dunkel, oder?
Der sieht doch gar keine Gegner.
Ah ja, alles klar.
In the ask shot, shoot it.
Alter, der flippt ja voller aus bei Battlefield 4.
Da kommt es ja vor wie 2014.
In Battlefield 4.
Next up, it's Prolosco,
with some high-skill Scout-Helicopter-Gameplay,
dropping in a few
only in Battlefield moments
along the way.
Oh nee, Heli-Action ist langweilig.
Ich will keine Heli-Action sehen.
Keine Heli-Action.
Ich will Infanterie-Action. Jawoll.
Jawoll, schön C4 reintroppen.
Die Musik im Hintergrund.
Ja, so muss das sein.
Schön alles wegsprähen.
Warum die Gegner hinter ihm nicht auf ihn schießen, ist...
Ich sehe ihn.
...ein nicht weiter zu beachtendes Detail, ja.
Ich frage mich, auf welchem Server die immer solche Gegner finden.
China-Server.
Auf der anderen Seite, du hast permanent eigentlich sowas, ne?
Und ich meine, es sind ja immer nur Ausschnitte.
Das kann sein, dass er das rechtliche Game auf den Sack gekriegt hat,
ein cooler Ausschnitt. Das ist in Battlefield halt so.
Du hast mal in Battlefield auch durchaus in der Runde,
wo es nicht so gut läuft, mal so 3-4 Minuten,
wo du übelst ownst.
Aber meistens sind es dann auch richtig gute Spieler,
die eh immer oben sind.
Ja.
Hahaha.
Da werden sie wegziviert, so muss das sein.
Übrigens, übrigens, richtig nice,
dass man, also Battlefield, Battlefield 3 und 4,
da war ja Recon, äh, Recoil Control eh easy, ne?
Du warst bei den Waffen einfach nur in einem gewissen...
Intervall schießen müssen, bei manchen sogar Lauerfeuer,
und leicht nach unten ziehen.
Fertig, kein Recoil.
Oh.
Ich finde, ich finde Heli- und Flugzeugclips Resident Sleeper.
Ich finde das mega langweilig.
Nicht, dass man das, nicht, dass das nicht gute Leute sind,
aber ich finde Heli- und Flugzeugclips,
mega Sleeper.
Nicht Resident Sleeper, mega Sleeper.
Battlefield 2042 muss ja im Prinzip diese Map mal 5 sein von der Größe.
Boah, das ist mega Resident Sleeper, Alter.
Er fliegt halt rum und basht Schiffe.
Ja.
Das ist sicherlich nicht easy,
vor allem auch permanent, äh, nicht getarget zu werden,
oder irgendwie, ja.
Aber ich finde es halt, Chatclips, langweilig.
Wann kommt Battlefield 2042?
Äh, wann ist es? Oktober? November?
Hab ich wieder vergessen.
Bäm.
Zack.
Heh, in den Arsch.
Das stimmt, das stimmt.
Das hast, das hast du, das hast du echt selten.
Melee-Kills mit dem Granatwerfer.
Oder Direct, Direct Impact Kills mit dem Granatwerfer, so rum.
Wow, die Granate ist ganz knapp an ihm vorbei,
die, das RPG.
Das DLC-Map, ja.
Tchuuu.
Jawoll.
Das sind Snipe-Clips, die lass ich mir gefallen.
Bäm, bäm, bäm.
Was ist denn mit dem Dude los da oben?
Will der nicht mal auf ihn zurücksnipen?
Oh, der war knapp, der war knapp.
Gut, dass die immer stehen bleiben zwischendurch.
Mangusti ist nächst mit drei kurzen Clips
auf Operation Metro.
Diese sind alles um Akkuratität.
Er geht wirklich aggressiv in die Recon-Klasse.
Das war ein echt nicer Headshot.
Das hier.
Nicht schlecht.
Ich hätte fast gedacht, es war ein Collateral eben.
Ah, der erste ist nicht gestorben.
Aber nicer Clip, das war ein cooler Clip.
Ganzen Schneibers.
Natürlich hat die Map immer noch die gleichen Bugs.
Meinst du, das hätte irgendjemand gefixt die letzten acht Jahre?
Bäm.
Er wurde von Fußbodenheizung gekillt.
Shit, Alter.
Das ist erniedrigend, von Fußbodenheizung gekillt zu werden.
Wieso, wie alt bist du?
Also ich bin jetzt sieben und, äh, noch nicht ganz, aber fast siebenunddreißig.
Und wenn ich Battlefield spiele, dann geht das immer noch.
Wird immer noch gebasht.
Neunundvierzig.
Okay, dann weiß ich.
Ich hab noch zehn Jahre Zeit, was zu ownen.
Danach ist es vorbei.
Die Legehähne, jawoll.
Boah, die lassen sich...
Wisst ihr, das verstehe ich manchmal nicht.
Warum liegt der Typ da?
Der Typ eben hier.
Warum liegt der da?
Der da.
Was, was, was macht der da?
Es macht doch überhaupt keinen Sinn, da zu liegen.
Was ist seine Mission, genau?
Was hat er vor?
Er hat den Clip zu Beginn eingeschickt, aber Prolosco hat mich mit ein paar Klicks von seinem Stream eingeschickt.
Er streamt ziemlich viel, also ist es definitiv wert, das zu beobachten, als wir bis zum Release für 2042 hochlaufen.
Der erste ist ein Highlight von Goldmode Railway, da er einen ziemlich großen Killstreak hat, wie er es normalerweise macht,
aber er schießt fünf Knochen in einem Rund.
Hier sind ein paar davon, wenn wir nur ein Teil des Streaks schauen.
Insane Akkuratur von einem der besten Piloten und einem der besten Spieler in Battlefield 4.
Man, wenn du fünf machst...
Wow, der war gut.
Nein, nein, das war wirklich verrückt.
Nein, das war wirklich verrückt.
Und sein letzter Clip ist etwas episches.
Ich war tatsächlich im Heli mit ihm, als er diesen kleinen Trick auf Cesar Shanghai machte.
Und ich denke immer, dass wir auf einen Crash gehen werden.
Echt episches Ding.
Was zur Hölle?
Okay, das ist mal ein schönes Heli-Fliegen.
Ein Locker-Clip. Es ist Eros mit einem riesigen M249-Backrage.
Es ist etwa eine Minute lang von ihm, der die Spieler dominiert.
Backrage, jawoll.
Zeig mir die Backrage.
In Battlefield 4, im Vergleich zu Battlefield 3, ist Support mit LMGs tatsächlich relativ beliebt.
Einfach, weil du die nachladen musst und nicht suppressed wirst und Leute suppressen kannst.
In Battlefield 4 konntest du ja nur mit der LMG Leute suppressen, wenn ich noch irgendwie das richtig im Kopf habe.
Wenn ich noch irgendwie das richtig im Kopf habe.
Oh, das ist nice. Also die Magnum-Kills sind immer nice zu sehen.
Ups.
ACR, beste.
War meine mit Abstand Lieblingswaffe in Battlefield 4, ACR.
Die Map unduliert und man hat einen guten Cover, zumindest bei diesen M-Comps.
Man bekommt es nicht wirklich.
Also können die Fahrzeuge einen Field-Day gegen dich haben.
Und oft findest du dich zurückgepinnt.
Wenn du jemanden wie Dusty auf deinem Team hast, der sich auf die Objekte kümmert und so viele Kills wie möglich bekommt,
ein aggressiver Infanter, dann bist du in Glück.
Das ist ein guter, weil er die Gegner-Spieler aufsteigt, um die Objekte zu spielen, um es für sein Team zu klären.
Eins muss man sagen, was sie immer hinbekommen haben in Battlefield ist richtig geiler Sound, oder?
Fällt euch in Battlefield ein, was Kack-Sound hatte? Mir nicht.
Auch wenn die letzten zwei nicht meins waren, soundtechnisch waren die sicherlich auch extrem gut.
Wobei ich ja sagen muss, Battlefield 3 bzw. Bad Company 2...
Bad Company 2 mit Wartapes, beste.
...all Area, but at the same time...
You've also got a lot of players coming from different angles.
It's more players on a smaller part of the map, as opposed to Conquest,
where people tend to be spread out a lot more.
A nice aggressive infantry play.
Granatu!
Willkommen, Radu!
Rekt.
Thanks for watching this episode of the Battlefield 4 Top Plays.
GG Eats!
Das habe ich mir auch gerade gedacht. Für Battlefield hat er eine ziemlich niedrige Sense.
Ich spiele in Battlefield auch absichtlich immer ein bisschen höher,
weil ich keinen Bock habe, hier einmal über den Schreibtisch zu kurbeln für eine halbe Drehung.
Das sind alles die ehemaligen CS-Pros,
die quasi erstmal einen Kilometer rennen für eine halbe Drehung.
Was war denn eigentlich schlecht an Battlefield 1?
Kann ich nicht sagen. Ich habe Battlefield 1 nie richtig gespielt.
Hat mich null angesprochen.
Ich habe die Beta gespielt, hat mir nicht gefallen.
Und... joa...
Schwer zu sagen.
War nicht mein Fall.
Battlefield 5 habe ich ein bisschen gespielt.
War auch in Ordnung, aber hat mich auch nicht so gecatcht irgendwie.
Deswegen, ich habe echt große Hoffnung Battlefield 2042.
Aber...
Wie gesagt, nicht vorbestellen.
Und am Ende kann es sich immer noch scheiße spielen.
Es bringt nichts, wenn ein Spiel aus ganz vielen guten...
...Teilen besteht.
Oder aus...
...aus vielen Teilen mit Potenzial besteht.
Wenn die nicht zu einem gesamten guten Game zusammengefügt werden.
Und aktuell sieht es halt aus, als hätte Battlefield 2042 schon viele Teile mit Potenzial.
Aber ob da ein gutes Gesamtgame dabei rauskommt...
Das müssen sie erstmal beweisen.
Ich würde es mir ja wünschen.
Dass ich mal wieder ein Battlefield habe, wo ich Bock habe jeden Tag den krassen Battlefield-Crime zu machen.
Bam, bababam, bababam.
In your face.
Immer noch EA.
Ach gut, es ist nicht so, als hätte nicht EA auch gute Spiele gemacht.
Oder raus... raus...
...published.
Die werden...
Die werden garantiert...
Die...
Da hat man ja schon gesehen, dass die die Warzone-Monetarisierung-Geschichte machen.
Mit...
...Season Passes und sowas.
Wie viel sollte ein frischer Softwareentwickler, der 1,5 Jahre als Werkstatt in der Firma gearbeitet, verdienen?
Was sagst du?
Wie gesagt, ich kann da nicht wirklich viel zu sagen.
Es kommt ganz entscheidend darauf an, in welcher Region und in welcher Bereich.
Und in welcher Region und in welcher Branche du bist.
Ich kann es echt schlecht sagen.
Es gab bei Heiser erst letztens eine Umfrage.
Ja, Helium-Mining habe ich schon gehört.
Über LoRa.
Aber...
Ich glaube nicht, dass das irgendwie was wird.
Oh, ich habe Hunger.
Und zwar ist es erst 12, wie lange bin ich denn schon on?
2.20?
Hm...
Book... ich bookmarke mir das mal.
Sessions?
Session?
Keck W, bester Name.
Alle Tabs gebookmarkt.
Weil ich glaube, ich gehe mir jetzt was zu essen machen.
Und ich nehme nachher noch ein Video auf.
Wie gesagt, ich wollte eh ein Video aufnehmen zu diesen Cheat-Geschichten, was LevelCaptor auch gezeigt hat.
Finde ich ist ein interessantes Thema.
Und ihr habt mich...
Ihr habt mich auf ein paar Ideen gebracht im Chat heute für ein neues Video.
Für neue Videos.
Einmal...
Einmal, dass ich über mein eigenes Vorstellungsgespräch damals zur Ausbildung erzählen könnte.
Könnte.
Da gab es ein bisschen mehr zu erzählen, was ich hier im Stream gemacht habe.
Plus...
Ich fand, das ist eigentlich auch ein gutes Thema gewesen.
So was da, was aktuell schief läuft.
So mit Vorstellungsgesprächen.
So diese ganze...
Wie viel Smarties passen in einen Smart?
Und sowas.
Dass sich viele Firmen für das nächste Google oder Facebook halten.
Obwohl sie irgendeine Software-Klitsche aus irgendeinem Kaff sind.
Gucken wir mal.
Silicon Valley habe ich nicht gesehen.
Ist das nicht so eine Comedy?
Ist das nicht so eine Comedy-Serie?
Da habe ich ein paar Ausschnitte davon gesehen.
Ist das die?
Ist das die Serie, wo es...
Wo es dieses...
Diese...
Sagen wir mal in Anführungsstrichen...
Berühmte...
Berühmte Szene gibt.
Wo sich der Typ mit seiner Freundin drüber streitet.
Ob Emacs oder Vim.
Was ist das?
Okay.
Ja, da kenne ich nur diesen Ausschnitt.
So, schauen wir mal.
Wer ist denn on?
Wen kann ich denn mal hosten hier?
Der...
Frasier ist nicht da.
Der Frasier spielt wieder irgendwelche Mobile-Games.
Da will er eh nicht von mir gehostet werden.
Okay, Leute.
Ich gehe.
Ich gehe jetzt auf.
Ich gehe mir was zu essen machen.
Bis denn.
Wir sehen uns.
See you.
Ciao.